the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody to the inaugural
edition of the american cup one of the
most fun and exciting new chess
tournaments hosted by the saint louis
chess club behind me is the bush stadium
home of the most valuable franchise in
st louis the saint louis cardinals
speaking of most valuable we have the
most valuable chess players in the
nation battling for the cavity title of
american cup champion let's go to the
studio and start this exciting day with
yasser and alejandra
it's a beautiful spring day here in st
louis it's in the central west end the
st louis chess club and we are ready to
bring you a spectacular event the
american cup 2022. i am grand master
alejandro ramirez here to bring you all
of the action with the legend himself
grandmaster yes sir sarah won alejandro
it's such a great pleasure to see you
again nice to be with you it's a
pleasure to have you back and what a
great event we have it's not the typical
round robin where people are trying to
vie for position draw strategically none
of that we have a double elimination a
brand new format here at the st louis
chess club this is going to be an
exciting one absolutely just win baby
hello welcome to our live coverage of
our very first 2022 american cup as
alejandro was saying it's a double
elimination match event and let's take a
look at the roster of players alejandro
it's a star-studded field in both the
open and in the women's let's start with
the open group a it is headlined by the
new american grand master levon aronian
with
27.85 feed it absolutely fantastic but
check out those three fellows following
him absolutely top rated players fabiano
carona wesley so linear dominguez
they're no strangers to the spotlight
they're incredibly strong
players here and
check out the rest former u.s champion
sam shanklin is here followed by three
youngsters sam savion jeffrey shong and
ray robson who are trying to make their
mark here in the tournament absolutely
and those last four look like an olympic
team as well and in the women's group
group b in the women's group we have a
ton of u.s women's championship between
the top two ladies they are no strangers
to winning here in st louis they're
irena crush and anna satonski but
they're joined by a lot of new blood
sarula tolaquiro who is now a student at
st louis university just down the street
yeah she's going to be new here at the
saint louis club a very talented player
and also a very experienced player is
going to be katharina nemtsova they're
on scene number four another university
student guru pekim tokidorowa who is
studying at mizzou missouri at colombia
here in missouri she is a very strong
player got second at the us women's
championship exactly last year and check
out that new
face here alice lee 23 34 rating you
might be wondering how come i haven't
heard of this player before it's because
she is on a meteoric rise and she's only
12 years old 12 year old obviously
he's going to be joining us here another
veteran we have tatev abrahamian and yet
another youngster ryu yang yan with 2283
only 15 years of age a very young field
there fantastic that veterans and youth
and our format uh alejandro that's where
it gets exciting yes sir we have a 10
day double elimination tournament we
have two different events
the open and the women's to eight player
double elimination knockout what does
this double elimination mean basically
everybody gets two lives if you get
knocked out for the first time in a
match you can still continue the
tournament you will be dropping down to
an elimination match so we're gonna be
having two different brackets everybody
starts at the champions bracket the
championship bracket with their two
lives and they will slowly be whittling
those down there will be no draw offers
allowed in any game here at the event
they're gonna have to find some kind of
threefold repetition or some kind of
dead drawn end game no draw offers
allowed but let's take a look at the
championship bracket
it's gonna be a classical time control
as long as you have fast pace a
fast-paced one that is very true 90
games for the 90 minutes for the entire
game with the 30 second increment
throughout but check it out no second
time control you don't get additional
time i move 40 you don't get additional
timer move 60. it's a
faster classical single time control for
the entire game now let's say that you
lose one of your matches you drop down
to the elimination bracket that's going
to be also known in a lot of esports as
the losers bracket this one you're not
going to be playing classical chess
anymore you're going to be playing for
your life
in rapid 25 plus 10 we're going to
switch out the format on those players
and that's gonna be absolutely thrilling
as we see the players claw for survival
right and of course these are mini
matches of two games each you play
against the same opponent twice once
with white and ones with black if that
mini match is tied the playoff time
control is simple ten plus five and the
winner of that moves through if still
tied after the playoff time control then
we have everybody's favorite after the
two rapid games we have armageddon if
needed that means that white starts with
five minutes black starts with four but
white must win the game a draw would
mean the black moves on there will be a
two second increment added started at
move 60 for the armageddon game only and
our schedule oh it's going to be an
exciting one we see seven of the players
already up there all right some of the
university players there we have
cathedral silva
and let's take a look at the schedule
uh
champions bracket is starting today
we have
four matches in each section and they're
all classical classical time control 90
plus 34 today uh same as tomorrow and
friday we start eliminating people yeah
sir exactly but also there will be
playoffs on tomorrow's round if
necessary and as you were saying on
friday we start eliminating absolutely
let's take a quick look at what happens
on friday that's such a key day as we
will have people
leaving the tournament on friday they
will be eliminated that day already so
this is a very fast paced tournament you
can see the championship bracket and uh
how group a and b will have two
classical games but in the elimination
bracket
tons of rapid games to be seen there
people will be fighting for survival
friday's gonna be a very exciting day
but we start with the classical today
absolutely and christian would you
first of all good to see you my friend
drill down on some of these matches for
us will you please yasser alejandro
always a pleasure to be back here in the
studio in st louis casting the games of
the best chess players on american soil
and what an event we have you guys
covered very nicely the format is a very
new and exciting format but let's take a
look at the brackets we're going to
start with a bracket in the open section
we have four incredible matches
leveronian the favorite rating favorite
is going to be facing ray robson
dominguez is going to be facing sam
shanglan that's a very close matchup
wesley saw vs sam savion and of course
fabiano caruana versus jeffrey shong but
one match that i'm definitely having my
eyes on is the one between aronian and
ray robson because these two players
have never faced each other it's very
rare at the top that you're going to
find two players that have never played
against each other they don't have any
information covering the other player
this one is going to be a very exciting
matchup let's take a look at the women's
section as well for of course we have
four very exciting matchups in this one
we start with crush versus rue
and the matchup that i'm definitely
having my eyes on is the one between the
eight-time national champion irina crush
versus rue yang yen the up and comer she
was 2100 rated yeah last year in the
junior section right now she is close to
2300 this is going to be a very intense
matchup guys this is a new and exciting
event and i'm looking forward to calling
all the action with you guys thank you
christian and i've got to say as much
action as we're going to be seeing in
the next 10 days we also have a blitz
tournament coming up with 40 top top top
players
players in this event as well as in st
louis alejandro absolutely what a crazy
10 days of chess we're going to have
here in the singles chess club and if
that wasn't enough take a look at this
event it's on friday april 29th we're
gonna have players that were eliminated
in the championship section players that
were eliminated in the women's section
we're gonna have nine blitz rounds with
some of the best chess players around
the city
and that is nothing to be laughed at we
have the national collegiate champion
san luis university will participate in
missouri university will be
participating webster university will be
participating some of the best blitz
players are very young they're going to
be here trying to prove their medal
that's going to be an exciting one but
we already have
with us
tony rich to introduce the event
hello welcome to the playing hall my
name is tony rich and i'm the executive
director of the st louis chess club
we're very excited to host for the first
time the american cup a double
elimination knockout format featuring
the best players in america
as the players get settled in our chief
arbiter chris byrd will give them a few
remarks and then we'll begin the round
back to you guys
thank you tony as uh again uh the
american cup
the first of its kind here in the united
states these double elimination match
events
i always thought the world cup needed
that because it was so harsh to travel
to the feed a world cup you go
10 000 miles 10 000 kilometers and you
lose the first game and you're
eliminated yeah
i felt that twice i have to tell you you
feel very good it's a double elimination
match gives you as you said that second
life
and gives you a lot of chance to just
get back in the tournament and there we
see lavonna rooney in the tournament
pre-tournament favorite against ray
robson in this blue blazer i remember
him from the u.s championship loving
that i love the system i love also the
fact that we switch the time control on
them you want to play classical chess
you have to go through the top you have
to win it in classical
if you lose once you lose one of your
lives one of your mini matches yep
that's it you have to play rapid and we
know that's more random exactly and a
much much harder and the playoff also i
like the fact that you're speeding up
the tempo of the game and
then it becomes a match of nerves
absolutely 90 of these players have
never played this format again the rest
have played it but maybe in online games
these guys are going to be taken out of
their comfort zone and this is exactly
what we like to see they were getting a
couple of shots of the players before
the game who gets started rina crush our
eight-time u.s champion she's looking
good lavon oronian
also seems to be
familiarizing himself with the
championship wall there you got the wall
of fame right there he is definitely not
a stranger to playing here in st louis
many times player of the sing field club
won it once but first time playing as an
american here in the singapore and also
again this time control is a speedy
time control it's a single time control
90 minutes for the entire game with a 30
second bonus for each move played as we
hear chris byrd mentioning some
final words
as the players just getting ready to go
this matchup that we have our camera on
right now i think you're like is the
closest one
shenzhen is definitely having the
momentum on his side uh lanier we know
him he plays very very thorough chess he
is a a very very good classical player
so but he's going to probably change the
tempo if this matchup goes into the
rapid and blitz portions
alejandra i gotta ask you a question how
do you win 200 rating points in a single
year
what is your secret
k-48
i
wow that's the only way but we have some
incredible talent here at this
tournament as you were mentioning yasser
yeah not one but two players that have
gone 150 200 points up
over there in the women's section alice
lee and ryan young
incredible as we are on the way underway
we have the games opening up
one c4 it looks like yeah
yep one c4 there for le monronian who
has
really expanded his repertoire in the
last let's say three to five years
he was exclusively a d4 slash c4 player
forever and he decided wait a second
four i need to put this as part of my
repertoire started playing e4 but did
not become exclusively an e4 player also
muddying the waters with other english
or d4 setups and i'm very curious about
this one christian was mentioning
himself they've never played against
each other in classical chess i find
that remarkable because these are two of
the top top players in nhs exactly rapid
blitz nothing maybe they played online
without knowing
with their secret accounts but in
classical chess they have absolutely no
information about their uh rivals
gentlemen as it's uh the start of the
first
game i'm gonna have to put
put us under a little bit of a pressure
as it's time for us to un
unveil
our predictions already yesterday it's
very early give us a few moves don't
understand this
no
i don't want i don't want a result man i
want you guys to under pressure
and
christian
we'll give you the first shot
um
well look in both i've been following
leveronians uh games for the past year
and it seems like he's hitting a stride
uh both in classical but also in a rapid
he just won the rapid championship on
chess.com for this uh past week right so
he's definitely in very good shape i
feel he has the edge over ray robson in
this matchup so i'm going to go with
leveronian to win the whole thing
alejandro well in the open section i
think it comes down to who has been
doing the most training recently and
there is a player here headed to the
candidates i know that he has been
studying non-stop he's having also great
results in the rapid chess championships
hosted online i think fabi is the
favorite for me even though he has
dropped below his usual 2800 he's
definitely hit a slump
but i think that he has to rectify this
ship in the next couple of months the
candidates is such a big event coming up
in madrid in june and that he has the
tools necessary to rebound all the way
up to 2800. alejandro unfortunately i'm
with you a hundred percent on everything
you said i've been following the
chess.com rapid championships and by the
way that's like
murderers wrote
those events are incredible and
uh fabi's playing some of the best rapid
chess of his life
he it feels like it's coming together
for him i'm gonna go with
uh fabi as well in the uh open and as
far as the women's are concerned once
again christian over to you uh draw
first blood
who do you like in the women well i'm
going to have to go away with my student
this is a very subjective thing i'm
going to go with gulruk begin to kill
jeanova on this one
begum who was second in the u.s
championships and how about yourself
alejandra i mean the formula is clear
yeah i also have a student in the
women's side if you don't
pick her i've been in a lot of trouble
but my students tabulator
who is a part of the national champion
team of st louis university uh she's my
pick she's a very strong player she's
i'm a little mercurial there will be
times where she plays amazing there will
be times and she's the player on the
left here facing against the talented
alice lee the 12 year old the youngest
player in the middle section and that's
intimidating it is
if you play somebody that has won 200
rating points in like three months
you feel that these players are really
making a lot of progress exactly there's
gonna be a great matchup it's a very
close one but i'm gonna go with starula
for winning the women's
now guys you both pick fabiano right in
the open section and you were mentioning
alejandro that it very much matters that
he's been training and preparing for the
candidates but will he use the
preparation for the candidates in this
tournament or is he going to be um not
using those uh those openings that he
has been working on and maybe some other
residual openings from previous
preparations that's very true but before
that let's look let's not forget that
arena she's she's been number one in
american women's chess for so long and
she's always a competitor she's fierce i
i got to go with arena fair enough arena
crush of course difficult to say no to
her she is not the number one right now
but we are unfortunately missing chris
yip due to school obligations
same thing
yes but you're right i mean uh
maybe not number one by rating but boy i
tell you it's so hard for
for uh me to vote
not for arena in this event so i'm going
with arena okay we've
we've made our results but let's jump
into the game and the game that i've got
up on my screen is the one between levon
aronian and ray robson and this is right
out of the uh world championship match
except for the move c7 c5 uh knight's e6
96 was uh magnus carlson's uh you know
when we used to
make the setup as white we did it as a
way of getting into a favorable catalan
where the move d5 takes c4 was
oftentimes not the best idea at this
moment and the move
i have to say when i saw this move first
in dubai being played i was thinking
myself my god these guys don't know
their stuff
i mean but after knight f3 knight c6 was
the move and after knight c6 uh actually
uh magnus got a very decent game and
never had any troubles in that game uh
but c5
yeah it's also a well-known way of
playing it's a reverse benoni if you
want to call it that way
white will very soon break in the center
with a move e3 you can castle first you
can even consider playing some sort of
benko gamut with the move b4 but that's
different channels all together i think
the current state of theory is that
black is doing fine in this position
despite the extra tempo that white gets
in this relatively sharp positions but
it's not just the extra tempo alejandro
it's also the fact you've committed
yourself to e6 too right that's okay
yeah so you do commit yourself to e6 i
understand the reluctance to push it
twice to g5 but there are many
situations in which you actually just
keep the pawn on e6 and even though your
bishop on c8 is maybe a little bit
crying so we're just looking at some
uh
let us say expected
expected
e2 e3 and
um
you say
the the theory is perfectly okay the
theory is that black is doing okay here
usually the knight goes to f6 normally
the bishop actually develops to c5 i've
seen it developed to d6 as well it
develops to e7 as well but people have
been putting it on c5 where it looks a
little awkward right but it's difficult
to prove a lot of advantage against it
and white plays the usual benoni type
bishop d6 is fine bishop c5 is fine
bishop e7 is fine
all of them are all of them are okay
okay i've seen people play h6 people
have been experimenting a lot in the
structure white is very willing to go
into this is far from a dry position
exactly but black says wow why can't we
make it a three result game let's go for
it i don't mind playing these structures
black does have the typical benoni
advantages you get the space you get
free play for your pieces if you get the
move e5 in you can even start thinking
of strategic strategical advantages this
is a very nuanced position guys and you
can actually get to it or something
similar from other move orders as well
very often we see this uh start with
knight f3 d5 and now we see c4 on the
board allowing the move d4 after which
in general we see this move b4 which
leads to some very very intriguing
positions and of course you were
mentioning the pawn already in the game
situation is already on e6 now with the
pawn on e7 you have extra options
actually one of the main moves in this
position is the sacrifice g5
trying to attack this knight on f3 gain
some space on the king side and if you
take of course now we see the idea of
leaving the pawn behind on the seventh
rank playing in one tempo e5 attacking
the knight on g5 of course if you go
back i'm going to continue with e4 and
i'm just going to destroy your position
so this is a very intriguing way in
which levon
maybe has tricked his opponent at the
beginning forcing him to play this move
e6 well of course ray probably uh has in
his repertoire e5 as well but he decided
to go with e6 g3 d5 bishop to g2 and now
without the knight on f3 we see this
move d4 now an intriguing
point in this certain situation is that
white's main move right now is actually
except knight f3 is the main move but
also b4 very closely behind if you take
of course this bishop on g2 just loses a
piece after queen to a4 the usual
defense with knight c6 doesn't work
anymore because the bishop is on g2
already bishop take c6 i'm going to next
capture on b4 and you're down a piece
you cannot do that now guess the move
the main move for black after the move
b4
guys i'll give you three seconds what's
the main move for black e5 e5 e6 to e5
you played e6 and now you're going to
play e5
very intriguing uh setup for both sides
it's a circus exactly because right now
if you go d3 i'm going to take on b4
with a tempo so what's your next move if
you go knight to f3 then i can go e4 and
immediately attack the knight on f3 very
interesting position it seems like queen
to a4 might be the computer's choice but
of course we know this position is very
nuanced and let's see who knows the
nuances better
wow thank you for that uh christian
seriously some very insightful stuff and
i used to play the english my whole
career
and that g5
was remarkable by the way uh varujin
kobien grandmaster version upstairs in
the production house uh
picked lavon as well
one game i really like to turn our
attention to is the game between lanier
and sam shanklin because
these guys have been blitzing it out
while we might be talking about move
three four five and six in levon's game
these guys are already
moved like 18 and we have a peace
sacrifice
as far as i'm aware
alejandro everything is theory right up
to this point yeah i just want to make a
very quick note please
a couple months ago white throws in this
move a4 yeah
that is all about it's a subtlety that
it can only be explained because of
engines and trust me that it is beyond
the scope of most chess players a4 and
a5 is thrown in because down the line
there will be some variations in which
it benefits either white or black it's
actually it does both it's not clear who
it benefits it just changes the position
okay but we go down the road of theory
in ibd2 this is all well known is better
known without the pawns on a4 and a5
okay this inclusion changes things later
as we'll see but let's go down the line
and i think
for me the movie bishop b3 i think a lot
of people in our audience will be saying
why didn't he move his bishop to b5 and
keep the pawn defended except we know
that bishop b3 is the recommended move
of the engine yeah so the bishop b5 has
also been tried at top level chess so
they've tried everything here
the engine is not very useful in
analyzing this position because it
throws 0.00 everywhere oh really but yes
both bishop b5 and bishop b3 but bishop
b3 is considered to be the most testing
move queen takes d3 knight takes e5 this
is all very well known the only move
here for black to keep equality is the
move queen f5 it does seem like there's
a lot of tactics in the air yes but they
all kind of benefit white for example if
you take on d1 here just to give you a
quick look okay
and i take your queen on d3 and you take
my bishop on b3
i take your bishop not on b3 but on c5
the one on c5 and oopsy daisy the pawn
on b7 is hanging yeah as well as the
bishop on b3 and even this
has been attempted for equality for
black this is a game between farouza and
karayaki and i want to say okay
which ended in a draw actually okay so
it's also playable for black it just
gives you an idea of the breadth of
ideas that black has in this position
and how deeply the players analyze and
prepare their games absolutely but queen
five is considered to be more accurate
uh knight ef3 is the only way to push
for something here and by the way
as we we're going through the bowels of
theory here i'm sitting here saying
uh
for appearances sake
black's pieces are sure active yes
and after knight f3 as sam shanklin
played rook
fe-8 and the players quickly going down
again are we still in theory after this
piece you don't even have to guess
yasser look look at how sam is playing
not thinking at all in this position
just being banging
batman
is currently down a piece for three
pawns very handsome pawns too very
handsome white king in shambles only a
knight to defend it and yet it is white
usually the one that is trying to win
this position
uh we're being told that the move rookie
won only a couple moves ago i assumed
right here i assumed this one rook takes
one is a novelty i'm not really sure
what the other move was i assume it was
queen g3 right yeah
queen d1 was played before apparently
not i do not know that game but let's
forget about that rook takes c1 queen
takes e1 queen g3 and lanier also a very
studious player somebody that really is
never afraid of showing long lines of
knowing them all the way till the end
nier is one of those players that just
believes what his preparation tells him
doesn't second guess it it doesn't pull
a grist check where he thinks for 30
minutes to get the position he knows he
has been blitzing out as well queen f1
rookie we have all of these move on the
board black's attack looks incredibly
dangerous thank you yes it does
but it's kind of worked out this
position knight df-3 probably the only
move to defend against
and now we're probably going to see
something along the lines of knight to
e5 i think 95 might also be forced and
you might be thinking why is black ever
afraid here you have three pawns yeah
and you have unions great activity great
activity no no development for white to
really speak up so it feels to me like
white's on the back foot i mean why
isn't black signing up for this position
all the time the thing is the two the
three pawns are really not worth that
much because they're not they're on h3
and g3 and threatening to promote and
white has more than just a piece the
pair of bishops it's a pair of bishops
in an open position that if white
consolidates the king okay and if white
uh is able to trade off a couple of
strategic pieces especially the queens
right black's position falls apart
wow fast position absolutely falls apart
the bishops are way too strong it's
sneaky but it is very strong as we can
see the lifetime between dominguez and
glenn it is not so much one win for
lanier i can't think of it
and a lot of draws probably seen in a
lot of the us championships we've had
well the last draw between these two
players was of course at the u.s
championships and i remember that game
and they had a theoretical battle in
that one as well at some point shankland
stopped
he seems to have made the last
theoretical move at least the last known
theoretical move and then dominguez took
a 40-minute thing i remember that moment
and after that 40-minute thing shanklin
responded with a 40 minute thing of his
own so these guys definitely have some
history and right now after knight to e5
this is the key moment because white has
a couple of ways in which it can
simplify the position and try to stave
off the attack black's attack bishop to
f4 is one of them after queen takes that
f4 queen takes f2 of course we're
exchanging uh this uh two bishops you no
longer have this threatening bishop on
f2 around my king and after i think he
played the move he did and this was the
second option queen to e2 pinning down
this knight on e5 of course you cannot
take on f3 you would love to do that
queen takes e8 is just simply a
checkmate on the board so how are you
going to defend against this checkmate
on the board what king to f8 this is the
move let's see if he makes it i assume
that shanklin is already made on the
board he's still he already played it
quickly this is the first line of the
computer so we know that both of these
players have analyzed this at home the
question is who is going to remember uh
the preparation
later on in the game because we're going
to end up in a very complicated middle
game who has analyzed this position more
thoroughly bishop d2 mission
bishop to
david too and also i i feel a lot of
times it's a a better understanding of
what the engine is telling you yeah a
lot of the grand master games in this
long theoretical variations comes down
to that a very specific example that i
can think of is fabiano carona against
icaru 2016 london chess classic where
fabiano sacrifices a queen for the two
pieces yes in a very sharp night or and
the engines were saying 0.00 but fabiano
looked at the position and thought
practical practically no way
and find this very very narrow path to
equality and
was very far from finding it actually
got obliterated in that game so many of
these sharp long lines come down to the
understanding of what the engine is
telling you at the end and let's see who
is correct sometimes they face a lot to
a draw but uh as you can see here sam
maybe not fully remembering the move
bishop d2 seems to be the first one to
go into the think tank bishop to d2 is
it seems to be a wrinkle because bishop
to g5 is the recommended move by the
engine the idea of course is very
obvious you want to play bishop to ah4
and just win a piece on the spot and
right now the best move probably is
knight to g4 not knight takes f3 which
looks like a natural move and then also
you're going to pick up the bishop on g5
but this position after queen takes f3
you don't have enough time to take the
bishop on g5 because you're going to get
checkmated in one move we see the action
between the bishop on b3 on the left
side and the queen coming to f7 very
interesting position knight to g4 is the
right move and now we see the difference
between bishop to d2 and bishop to g5
bishop to g5 which is the computer
recommendation allows the queen to swing
to c2 this extra square the bishop d2
blocks it and maybe because of
this nuance shanklin did not consider
this at home who knows right now the
clock is ticking he knows he's out
potentially out of the theory and we're
going to see how he responds to this
challenge
thank you for that christian and
obviously these players they work
incredibly hard on the preparation in
fact i i do they have lives outside of
the chess world
what are they playing for alejandro what
what is bringing them to the american
cup in group a well something has to put
foot on the table it's not just looking
at variations it's proving them on the
board here at the american cup look at
that price fund 200 000
to be distributed first place will take
home 50
second place thirty five third twenty
five you can see there's a championship
bracket bonus if you win all you make it
all the way to the winners finals by
winning your classical games then you
will receive an extra ten thousand
dollars
as the championship bracket winner nice
very very nice and in group b
we have a hundred thousand dollars as
their prize fund twenty five thousand
dollars for first place 18 per second 12
for a third and again that championship
bracket bonus if you are the winner of
the winner's bracket you get an extra 5
000
very very very nice
and just to remind everybody this is
what the champions bracket looks like
remember this does not include the
elimination bracket which will be done
after we have uh
the completed the first match the first
match which is uh finishes tomorrow we
have aronia robson dominguez shankland
so savien and caruana against xiong and
you can already see how the brackets
feature on depending on who moves on we
could even have a karwana saw already on
the second round remarkable and in the
women's bracket crush will be playing
against riyan yan katrianem soa is
currently against tokyonova solaquido
against alice lee and ana satonski in a
classical matchup there against uh
tatava bahamian they actually have
played tons of times about the same
thing we we have one match where the
players never played each other
this matchup between uh
i mean they've played so many times
there's a trilogy going on over there
it's their whole encyclopedia they were
just in those games and they played
playoffs they played armageddon they
played classical they played all kinds
of stuff
and let's say let's take a look at well
like we even have the info let's see
lifetime matchup of cl just classical
just classical six wins four losses
that's actually pretty even right and 12
draws between them and don't get me
started on the rapids and the blitz and
all kinds of stuff so definitely very
familiar these players against each
other
and also for fabi who is coming in as
our number two seat and it's so rare
this player has been number two in the
world
for a number of years it feels like and
then he's coming into the match of the
second seat he's playing against uh
young jeffrey zhang who's fighting for
his olympic spot yeah you know it's very
very tough it's tough now it is and uh
just coming to this game uh draw our
attention here to this it came out of a
well russian defense or what we call the
petrov
and
what's
for me interesting is that jeffrey is
playing the petrov
against fabi and fabi used to have it in
his repertoire forever and ever it
seemed like to me the petrov that is to
say and fabi has just played this move
rook on e1 to e2
which had me stumped it's a bit of a
wrinkle the the main move of course is
to move rook b1 i think that we've seen
that time and time again yeah exactly
must have been what jeffrey expected
because we do see that he's starting to
think after the move rookie too rugby
one has been seen i don't know hundreds
of times maybe right very simple you
attack the phone on b7 but i remember
actually analyzing uh this particular
position with fabi uh in our 2018 world
championship preparation and we found
that there were some situations not all
of them and it wasn't clear cut where
the rook on b1 was actually just
superfluous yes it attacked the pawn and
it is in a half open file right but that
the moves b6 or knight a5 whichever way
you wanted to defend the pawn was
actually slightly more useful for black
than it was for white and it was a hard
argument to make but you could make it
sometimes but the whole point of rook e1
to e2 is of course you're intending to
double uh but you got to get the bishop
out of the way so why don't you get the
bishop out of the way first
then double rookie one rookie two uh but
you you uh fabi specifically didn't play
bishop to f4 let's see
and the reason for that is also very
subtle and
it's not that subtle the thing is that
the bishop on c1 might go to d2 and it
might go to f4 if you go to f4 directly
right you have the issue that in some
positions the move bishop d6 forces an
uncomfortable decision for for white not
immediately but in some cases if you
play bishop f4 here for example yeah
yeah uh oops sorry i was gonna go
yep there you go a bishop d6 is a common
uh alternative experience uh immediately
attacking the bishop and if the move
knight g5 doesn't work yeah which
looks like you you want to do
which has been analyzed kind of to death
i think really yeah there's a lot of old
game not old but like 10 year old games
in this variation where black plays g6
it looks a little scary for a few moves
it does it does it's very scary if you
don't know your theory but if you know
your theory the engines say 0.00 no
problems wow the problems in the
structure and the queen side more or
less compensate for the activity that
white has you actually don't get rated
on the kings and some people have but
but you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to get mated and it's supposed
to be okay for uh black so since this
was worked out the other option was to
put the bishop on d2 but it is a little
passive right so on the other hand the
move rookie two introduces the following
wrinkle
yes i am going to put the rook on e1 but
this bishop on c1 i am kind of keeping
that hand close to my chest do i want to
put it in four do i want to put it on d2
what are you going to do with this
particular tempo that you have right now
let me give you a couple of examples if
you play them with queen d7 yeah and i
put my bishop on f4 now queen 27 is a
natural move and i put my bishop on f4
this has all been seen before the idea
is that if you play bishop d6 now then
you've lost attention you lost the tempo
after all of these trades thank you
thank you for the tempo queen takes d6 i
bring my rook to e1 and this is the
dream this is the dream you get the free
e-file you get a little bit of an
initiative black's not losing or
anything like that but he's going to be
under a lot of pressure this is kind of
the simple one-move tempo subtleties
that white is looking for in this
position two result game christian okay
that was a brilliant demonstration guys
and i just want to add uh one uh wrinkle
to that after a by four bishop to d6
another uh interesting uh option for
white would be to go bishop to g5
attacking directly the queen on d8 now
of course if you go queen to d7 it seems
like after knight to e5 white does
indeed get some pressure because after
you exchange on e5 i'm going to be able
to expand with the move f4 and it seems
like white has the advantage but it's
important to understand that in this
position as black you're actually not
afraid to play the move f6 of course you
hear it from coaches all the time that
you should never play the move f6 but in
this particular position it's a very
very uh good and enforcing move for a
black structure because you're
controlling the important g5 we saw that
knight g5 always coming with a lot of
mating attacks but also this important
square knight to e5 and f6 simply
equalizes for black maybe even gives
black the initiative queen to d7 after
that i'm going to focus on the light
squares i'm going to make sure that
you're never going to be able to land
the knight on e6 which is impossible and
black's position is just going to be
fine but let's take a look
at this game between wesley soh and sam
sevion because we have a very intriguing
battle
this nimzo idea with e3 we see we've
seen this move e3 being played at the
top level quite frequently recently and
after castle bishop to d3 d5 now we see
this uh interesting a new idea first
played by levan aronian actually a
couple of months ago c takes d5 in a top
encounter he takes d5 it looks innocuous
it looks like white is not really
achieving anything why would you
exchange and release the tension open up
uh the diagonal for the light square
bishop it doesn't make a lot of sense
but there are some interesting nuances
a3 now
after a3 with the pawns already on c4
and e6 you could potentially take on c3
and then take on c4 and play the move c5
now after bishop takes c3 you no longer
have the option of taking on c4 so the
way white is going to continue i'm going
to play the move c4 and uh i'm going to
have the two bishops and you're not
going to have anything in return for
that not even an initiative on the queen
side so
of course black retweets with the bishop
on d6 and now we see this uh move queen
to c2 normally
as a beginner you are uh thought by your
coaches that you should develop your
minor pieces first you should go knight
to f3 or knight to e2 and then go castle
the idea here is that after queen to c2
you're actually waiting for black to
show you where he's going to put the
pawn from c7 if he goes to c6 which was
played in the game then i'm going to
develop my knight to e2
because with the knight on e2 i'm going
to have options
related with the move f3 and a potential
attack on the king side g4 h4 as we will
see in the game of course if it goes c5
black that is you don't want to go
knight to e2 because after the move f3
black already attacks the center with
the spawn on c5 and it's going to be
able this is by the way a tempo position
if you miss a tempo you're going to end
up in almost a losing position so it's
very very important that you wait and
see what your opponent is going to do
first now if you play the move c5
generally white decides to take on c5
and play against the isolated pawn c5
take on c5 bishop takes c5 knight to f3
and we continue the game into a
strategical middle game in which white
is going to focus on the isolated pawn
on d5 that's why in this position and by
the way uh sam savion played the move c6
showed his cards to his opponent one of
the best moves in this position is the
move knight to a6
it looks very strange right knight to a6
but this supports the move c5 because
after an exchange on c5 i'm going to be
able to recapture with the knight which
is a much better uh piece to land on c5
because after that is going to attack
for example let's say knight to f3 c5
take take we have this position and
right now uh of course after knight to
f3 by the way black should play c6 but
let's just uh look at this position the
knight on c5 is a much better placed
piece than the bishop on c5 you want to
land on e4 you're also attacking the
bishop on d3 so
for example as i was mentioning if
knight f3 actually the best move is to
go c6 not c5 c5 is against knight to g2
sorry knight to a6 knight to g2 and now
c5 comes on the board and it seems like
black will equalize it's a very very
complicated position white can take on
a6 and mass black structure but
black is going to play the move a6 later
on and bishop to a6 and he's going to
have a very nice control over this a6 f1
diagonal weakened diagonal by the
absence of the bishop on d3 so the
position is very very intriguing and he
played the move uh c6 first
uh sam savion that is who by the way is
brilliantly prepared in the opening
phase both wesley and sam sevilla he
played the move c6 now white responded
with a move knight to uh e2 rook 28
bishop to d2 he's preparing to actually
castle long and play the move f3 f3 he
starts off with f3 and now
we see the knight on e2 we lose the
tempo and we play c6 c5 it has to be
done you have to find the counter play
in the center with the move c5
h4
on the board what is this move well i'll
tell you what is this move for example
after c4 bishop comes to f5 and in
general you're going to want to harass
that bishop with the move g6 now if you
play the move g6 either here
either after h4 g6 trying to trap the
bishop with a move c4 i can actually go
h5 and after c4 i'm going to take on a
g6 you're going to take on d3 i'm going
to take on f7 king takes f7 queen takes
d3 i have three pawns
for the piece but a tremendous attack
and this seems to be a very good and
potentially a decisive attack for white
so wesley definitely knows about this
position he played the move h4 and right
now sam70 is wondering what is this guy
trying to do he's trying to kill me
right now on the king side look at him
thank you christian very uh in-depth
analysis there of the opening that move
knight a6 certainly
had
me uh completely surprised i'd like to
turn our to our attention to
the other bracket uh the ladies game and
let's start with my pick for a change
we're going to pick up
arena crush's game and from the opening
the move bishop b4 nimso indian with
knight f3 i've seen irina play this
nimzo uh basically her whole career and
she's really been one of those ladies
that like the
where's my mouse there it is come to me
who likes what i call the classical
she's played this a great deal in her
career uh knight f3 was her choice uh
for today and then came very quickly d5
not going into the normal nimso indian
channels
and
we've seen these
this
line
and the players got here very very
quickly so i assume they're all in their
preparations uh any particular insight
about this position that you have
uh it feels that irena got here with
more time i think that uh riyang as we
can see has spent a little bit more time
than her opponent exactly she played
very quickly did it really right this
this kind of structures actually
sometimes represent a problem for black
especially if you don't get a good hold
of the dark squares
if this bishop on g5
somehow makes it to d4
you can wonder where black's counter
play is right you have some pressure
over the c3 square that's a huge
bishop fortifies everything it cements
the entire queen side and summons the
entire center so my question is well you
play knight c4 i can see that my bishop
on g5 is kind of hanging if you drop
what if i drop it back and if we just
put a very natural
now as opposed to a move like rook c1
which you might also like you're all no
bishop e5 maybe immediately knight g4
maybe an ig4 let's put that on the board
yeah maybe that is important that's very
important because then you don't
you're getting double hit you're getting
hit on e5 you're getting hit on the f2
square which is why we probably should
have gone rook c1 and not been so
clever but you but the point you were
about to make is that once white's
castle and ever lands the bishop on d4
then it's advantage white just for the
two bishops and just this great bishop
the way i would see this position is
that white has the long-term ideas you
have two bishops you have a more
flexible structure in the sense that i
could break on c4 you cannot break on d4
right
and that it's black that has to prove in
the next couple of moves what her
initiative is going to bring her for the
two bits for the two bishops and the
possibilities in the long term so you
can see that black is better developed
it's already finished development and
white still has not castled but
something to prove here for black right
and here's a look at our eight-time u.s
women's champion arena crush very young
38 it seems like i've been talking about
arena's career
my whole career
she was so successful as a 14 year old i
think was her first
u.s women's championship i actually met
irina when i was nine years old that was
the first interaction i ever had with
her so i also have known irina my entire
life exactly you still talk about her
today as they receive the veteran of
women's chess
applying her craft shall we say yeah
she's always been an incredible player i
think that she
has put herself above the other women
participants in the u.s women's
championship specifically because of her
good positional understanding i think
that in tactics she has fallen for some
tricks here and there in important
events but when it comes to positional
understanding and how to handle certain
positions my gosh she's a very very
dangerous grandmaster and i'm not saying
that in that tournament specifically in
so many events that i've seen her play
this kind of
ragosans
classical queens indians uh all these
kind of positions she handles so so well
exactly and turning it back over to you
christian you're looking at you're
you're showing some very feisty pawn
sacrifices do share with our audience
well you guys made a very clever point
and that is if the bishop lands to d4
then strategically is almost game over
so i was looking at ideas after bishop
to f4 and uh this move came on the board
d4 just sacrificing the pawn like that
one two three four attackers
one defender for black well my coach
taught me that i'm not supposed to put a
phone on d4 because i'm going to lose it
for sure and you're definitely going to
lose it but what it does it empties the
square d5 for the knight takes advantage
of the placement of the bishop on f4 if
you take with the queen on d4 then i'm
going to continue with knight to d5 and
this is a much better placement for the
knight i'm attacking both the bishop and
four but also i'm putting a lot of
pressure on the pawn on c3 so for
example i think after uh d4 knight takes
d4 would be the best move knight to d5
queen to b2 and now just retreating the
bishop to g6 now this is a very
intriguing position i still give white
the advantage but it seems like after
knight takes f4 or even knight takes c3
despite the fact that you have the two
bishops after knight to c3 i'm going to
be able uh to equalize this position as
black the material is too limited and it
doesn't seem like i will have any uh big
weaknesses in the position as black so
d4 is a key move but of course we are in
this moment and bishop to f4 is not the
only move bishop to h4 is also an idea
and this turns once again into a very uh
intriguing strategical battle because
black is going to try to focus on the
weakness in white scam the pawn on c3
white of course is going to try to focus
on the weakness on d5 the isolated pawn
and also take advantage of this
beautiful square on d4 he's going to
maneuver she's going to maneuver uh her
pieces around the square d4 this is
going to be a very critical uh one
zatonski abrahamian i was just looking
at this game and i was trying to
understand
what are they thinking about
because we're at move eight we're still
in the trenches of theory right now
but it doesn't seem like they know uh
the theory and in this position the
abrahamian almost at one hour and 13
minutes on the clock one hour and 15
minutes on the clock for anna zatonski
we know anna likes to think a lot we've
seen her in so many u.s chess
u.s women's chess championships uh being
down to the wire in time trouble she
loves that time trouble situation and it
seems like abrahamian will follow her in
this game we're still in trenches of
theory and this one let's see how it
develops
alejandro tell us a little bit about
your student and what do you think about
the position in that game so lucky dude
versus the youngest player in the event
alice lee
well
christian if you thought that anna
satonski likes to take time playing her
moves in the opening you should see my
student
sarutal aquito one of a player that
loves time pressure absolutely adores it
and you can see it right now her
opponent with an hour and 33 minutes
left in the clock 33 yeah she's gained
she's gained three minutes and starula
of course is down to 56 minutes on her
clock coach is not happy meaning that
she spent 34 minutes while alice has
been blitzing out every one of her moves
yeah also kind of curious on why she's
thinking so long considering that this
is a well-known position of the queen's
gambit accepted exactly
a little bit of a wrinkle there if we go
back a couple of moves
people have been starting to play this
move bishop d3 uh pretty commonly here
a6 for the longest time bishop b3 was
the main move but people have been
trying b3 a4 even queen e2 bishop d3
knight c3 bishop e2 i've seen rookie one
dc5 all moves even b3 b3 bishop d3 okay
that still has
venom yeah it's been around yeah and
this b5 move i don't know it but it is
one of the top engine moves so it's a
novelty it's a novelty okay that makes
sense yeah
and then after the move e5 uh i
normally speaking when white gets in
this central pond duo one of the
things that you have to watch out for is
that
these types of pawn sacrifices
themselves do have some venom as well
but we did see the move e5 knight to d5
and as
we're witnessing uh white finally did by
the way just played the move knight to
c3 a pretty logical move i think exactly
this knight on d5 to my eyes looks like
a very good
uh piece let's get rid of it now the
question is after for if alice all 12
years old alice was to just
spank down the move bishop b7
well perhaps a little bit of a relief
there forced the role of fans as alice
does not plunk down a movement instantly
i was thinking finally right what an
unusual clock situation there and
remember there is no second time control
in this tournament there is no
hour added or 30 minutes added and move
40. none of that none of that business
you get those 90 minutes at the
beginning you get your 30 second
increment and that's it once those run
out you're out of luck first of all i'm
going to get in this
uh
compliment quite often throughout the
whole broadcast of the american crap
first of all congratulations on your
national championship and what an
extraordinary year as the saint louis
university uh
accomplished really really really
outstanding alejandro obviously you're
the head coach and what do you do when a
player does
get into time trouble often how what's
your cure coach
it's not an easy one it's something
psychological where they always seem to
regress into this problem it's something
that
is born with a player and if you don't
nip it off like very early it's
difficult to to say much but i do have
some rules for them uh there's many
players that i've given them a time
limit uh per move it doesn't matter how
complex it is you have to play
right you see that the clock has certain
x amount has passed you must make a move
even if it's a dumbest move on earth
it's better than not making the move
because you start getting used to the
fact that you need to move you need to
make those hand movements you need to
let your creativity flow and yes you
will blunder once in a while but you
will blunder less than you will blunder
later in the games where you're
guaranteed to go to be flagging it's not
an easy problem it's something that if
we had a solution grizzchick would have
already taken it exactly exactly and if
you ever come up with a solution we'll
put it in a can and we'll sell it for
9.95
i mean we'll make it 40 million
uh what do you have for us christian
it's impossible to solve that solution
is definitely that problem is definitely
impossible to solve because uh it's
psychological as you were mentioning and
that's a very good rule the i don't know
how many minutes you ask your players to
make their move authors i usually tell
them 10 minutes if they think for more
than 10 minutes there's a problem in the
position
another uh way you can challenge that is
try to stay close to your opponent's
time so for example if you uh get down
to your last 20 moves 20 minutes make
sure that your opponent doesn't have 40
50 minutes right make sure you're within
a five minute range to your opponent of
course as we get down to the shorter
time controls five minutes you cannot
five versus ten it's already a problem
you can be a pawn up you can have a
better position but if you're going to
have so much tension on your clock
you're going to be in trouble so uh try
to stay close to your opponent on time
at all times and uh even in blitz games
this is a big problem in blitz games as
well because i have a few students that
like to take their time in the opening
phase and then they have like one minute
versus four minutes and 30 seconds and
even if they have a winning position
they're definitely going to lose that
because their opponents are going to be
able to find ways to trick them you
don't have enough time to make your
decisions so make sure that if you're in
that situation where you don't have
enough time to make your decisions your
opponent is in the same situation as
yourself and uh i was just looking at
all the games in the latest sections it
seems like this uh game this matchup
between nemtsova and tokyo genova seems
to be quite peaceful right now we
started off with memsova first of all
is either a bishop to f4 london player
or e4 player and we've seen them
challenging each other in the u.s chess
championships as well in october last
year and in that match up she played the
move e4 she started off with the move e4
and we had a crazy position as early as
move uh six or seven after knight to f6
take
d5 e5 d5 bishop to b5 and now we saw
this move knight to d7 by tokyo nova she
actually won that game quite handily and
it seemed uh it seems like uh
nemtsova decided not to follow the ideas
in e4 and the openings in e4 and she
decided to start with d4 now we see
knight to f6 knight to f3 sidestepping
the usual london which we know to hija
nova probably was prepared against
knight to f3 g6 e3 very tame approach by
white bishop to e2 and now
b3
play b3 c5 immediately challenging the
center and after bishop to uh b2 take on
d4 knight to c6 we have this position on
the board one hour and 11 minutes for
tokyo genova one hour and 12 minutes for
nemtsova
well there's a reason these players have
identical ratings
they're very close to each other in
strength and this one is going to be a
very tense match-up thank you christian
for that and uh
first of all once again uh it's so nice
to be back in studio i just feel like
i've missed something for like these
last six months and it's great to have
everybody with us on the show but
there's a way
for you the audience to participate with
us and to join the show alejandro how do
people do that absolutely we have a
social media person i believe it is
costa kavutsky that is on twitter and
you can join the commentary with hashtag
the american cup we could also accept
hashtag u.s chess champs remember
that the best questions the most
interesting ones we will actually have
on air will be able to discuss among us
so tweet at uh hashtag the american cup
we will be browsing through them
choosing the best ones and having them
here answered live for you and don't
forget the best question
uh allows us to award ourselves a prize
for the best answer
so nice uh i wanted to turn our
attention back to the open section for a
moment because of the game between fabi
and
jeffrey when we left it we had been
talking about this very subtle and cagey
rookie 2 move and we said there was one
thing that maybe
black should avoid jeffrey plays the
natural queen d7 and after bishop f4
bishop d6 we got the exact position that
we thought was
the dream position for fabio well and
that and that's why jeffrey hasn't
played the move bishop d6 so he didn't
play not yet
right so in this position after bishop
f4 i i don't expect
uh bishop t6 i would think even putting
the rook on e8 is more logical although
and then the bishop on d8
we're being told by our producers that
this position has been seen eight times
i do not know exactly the state of
theory here but i expect that the move
bishop d6 is not the most precise
exactly guys to avoid that please put
that game to the side yeah yeah sure
so this game is just simply ridiculous
after the move h4 sam savion thought for
15 minutes and played the move h5 no
h5 are you going to weaken your king
just like that when you know that your
opponent with a move f3 is going to
support the breakthrough with the move
g4 and immediately wesley saw play the
move castle right he didn't think for a
single minute
a6 right now he's taking his first thing
g4 seems to be the move that you want to
play you want that breakthrough you want
to kill your opponent checkmate him on
the king side of course you cannot waste
any time because black is coming as well
on the queen side that's why he played
the move a6 preparing the move b5 the
expansion is coming fast i'm going to
play b5c for b4 i'm going to open up the
position on that side quite quickly and
your king is going to be in big danger
despite the fact that it has so many
pieces around it what you have to do as
soon as possible as white is
breakthrough with a move a g4
and put pressure on your opponent
because you know sam savion by his uh
time situation right now you know that
he probably did not analyze this
specific position at home he only has
one hour on the clock left after g4 he
has to take on g4 it seems like f takes
g4 is one move probably i can just even
lift this pawn on f3 and try to open up
the position with h5 but let's say f
takes g4 knight takes d4 nice takes g4
you're going to allow me uh to take the
central pawn on d5 while you take this
meager pawn on the side opening up at
the same time the g5 this is very
counterintuitive play from the black
side in this particular uh position and
if he doesn't do this if he plays
something like c4 and tries to open up
with b5 after bishop f5
the position is just simply over
looking
in time you're not in time because after
b5 g5 is coming with tempo you have to
move the knight away this pawn on d5 is
going to fall yeah the whole position
collapses so
it seems like after a6 wesley is going
to take his time right now he's taking
his first thing of the game one hour and
22 minutes for wesley one hour for sam
savion this is the game that we're going
to analyze for the rest of this
broadcast i have a feeling guys because
this one is explosive
i like the move g4 a lot i think a lot
of people in the audience would say hey
i even play rook g1 and g4 and that move
h5 it's a hook
it's a hook and it's a dangerous looking
move wow it really i i'm starring one
yeah i'm stunned it's great
understanding there by saying if it's a
good move but if it's a bad move you say
your king right
right right right absolutely
and we have a special cupid's sorry
absolutely we are uh selling a very nice
jacket i think we have a slicker a rain
slicker look at that's actually
beautiful nice compact unisex jacket
that features the st louis chess club
logo on the left and the 2022 american
cup logo on the back it's a great way to
support this lewis chess club and
support everything we do here it is
absolutely perfect for travel it will
keep you dry i guarantee you that and
you can buy it at
qboutiquestl.com again you can shop it
at
qboutiquestl.com have it on the screen
and you can be matching with the legend
yasser sarawan himself that is
absolutely the best thing you can do he
has one himself yes it's right over
there my bag of goodies and his bag of
goodies and with that we're going to
take a very short break we're going to
come back to some of the most explosive
games here and certainly to see how
wesley saw tries on the king's side
there against sam sebian we'll be back
in just a few
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lao meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing st louis is on
display all year long
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are here in
the first round of the 2022 american cup
it's a double elimination tournament
let's start with the initial brackets of
course is the champions bracket where
everybody still has two lives nobody's
in danger of going home today nor
tomorrow but already on friday people
will be in peril to start the champions
bracket we have thirsty lavonna ronyan
playing against ray robson the near
dominion against sam shanklin wesley so
against san sabian and fabiano corona
playing against jeffrey xiong in the
women's bracket we have again the same
format everybody has two lives nobody is
worried about going home tomorrow but on
friday they will be again in danger
irina crush is playing against ryan yan
katarina nem sova is playing against
gulrok beckham tohirionova sabulous
aquito playing against alice lee anna
satonski is playing against her all-time
rival tatev abrahamian absolutely and we
have some very nice games in the open
section in fact i want to say all four
games or all four matches in the opening
section are been great positions to
commentate from i'll turn to our number
one seed lavon aronian ray robson when
we had left it it was one of these
reversed benoni's
and
well how big is white's advantage that
is what ray is asking he played the line
with bishop d6 you mentioned that bishop
c5 also um
is known and after bishop takes f6
knight d2 white does want to
uh win back his two bishops he wants to
play the move knight e4 and then he does
want to eliminate this bishop on d6
which is why we saw queen e7
and then
i moved queen f6 i must say a little
weird right it's actually a fascinating
position the move knight b3 seems a
little bit awkward if you're familiar
with the benoni structures you know the
move a3 and b4 is coming very often to
expand on the queen side so it seems
like the knight is misplaced but it
comes as a very direct tactical problem
for black the bottom d4 is hanging in
you cannot play exactly the move e5
because knight takes d4 exploits that
weakness that pin on the e file and what
just ends up upon
so you kind of force this queen to go
back to f6 it's a little bit annoying
for black as well and after knight fd2
you again threatened to pick up the
bishop with knight e4 attacking both the
queen on f6 and the bishop on d6 that's
why the bishop drops back to c7 maybe
some cases also in some cases you can
hit f4 right prevent hardcore preventing
this move e5 from being played on the
position of course it leaves some dark
squares vulnerabilities behind the pawn
but we'll deal with those laters and
after the move a5 we have to move knight
c5 already on the board a fascinating
struggle as you can see this is not your
typical benoni white has a lot more
activity than you usually get in those
openings but what's the downside you
have sacrificed in some ways your
bishops you have giving up your [ __ ]
dark square vision for the knight on f6
black remains solid do you have a couple
of weaknesses down the diagonal b7 is
attackable d4 is attackable but black is
plenty active
a key question here for me as white is
if i get in the move queen a4 and maybe
queen b5 i'll be threatening after queen
a4 the move b4 hitting the knight on c6
for me it all comes down to how am i
going to meet the move queen e7 is there
something that's really immediately
obvious to you because well queen e7 i
don't want to put the knight back on e4
no then i've walked into this very big
tactic
f7f5 i've trapped my own knight in fact
so
what's my immediate answer to this move
queenie seven yes you wanted to go
knight to a4 maybe
knight a4 c5 and knight to c4 this is
what i'm thinking ah that's very clever
i like that exploiting this weakness on
the b6 square
so putting the knight on a4
it's an intriguing it looks great it
looks very strange it does uh my my
initial reaction would
was that i wanted to avoid playing that
i thought there was might be something
with b2b4 this is where i was actually
initially headed uh in this whole thing
right and i wasn't feeling well you can
show a couple of variations on why i was
the solution because of takes takes
takes on a1
yep uh queen takes a1 is forced and
knight takes b4 and if i had to move
uh queen takes d4 here available maybe i
would start considering this position
i'd see if i could deal with bishop b6
and stuff like that but unfortunately at
the end black simply has the move knight
c2 and that's that's it's curtains
because that is as you were about to
point out a double attack of massive
fork against the queen and the rook so
no queen takes d4 and no
b4 there'll be four therefore yeah but
maybe you're right maybe it's all about
knight a4 but i like knight a4 christian
you've got another donny brook uh to
share uh the game between lanier and sam
shankar what's happening there oh my
goodness well uh i was trying to
understand the preparation of these
players and i was trying to understand
what did lanier have prepared after this
queen to e2 knight to g4 which was
played in the game queen to f1 and right
now black had a couple of options you
have to deal with queen to g2 exchanging
the queens and then you're uh there's
going to be a lot of pressure on your
pieces now you have to take on h2 or
play the move knight to e3 which piece
are you going to eliminate from white's
camp and it does make a lot of logical
sense to go for the bishop on d2 because
these two knights they're superfluous
supposedly but also they defend the king
very well they're coordinated defending
the king very well we know that knights
next to the king are a very very good
defensive measure and knight to h2 seems
to have been a very intriguing try
because after a knight to h2 now you
have a couple of options as black both
of them tied to the same idea and that
is that i'm trying to swing this rook on
the h file and bring another attacker in
to the game and for example after rook
to e5 or rook to e4
queen to g2 would be the only move that
keeps the game going because black has a
clear idea for example if you try to go
rook to d1 and just improve your pieces
and try to
get into some sort of a better middle
game get your pieces into the game open
up the d file try to go rook to d8 get
an attack of your own after rook two h4
the game is over this is going to be a
draw because after queen to g2 i take on
h2 you take i'm going to give you a
check on f3 you're going to cover i'm
going to give you another check on h5
you're going to cover and we're going to
have a perpetual on the board this would
finish the game and i was trying to
understand how white can keep the game
going after this idea of knight takes h2
knight takes h2 which is forced and then
rook to e4 or rook to e5 both of them
kind of uh trying to get to the same
idea and that is landing on rook on h5
queen to g2 makes a lot of sense right
you're going to exchange the queens
you're defending against rook two h5
potentially
queen takes g2 king takes you to a now
rook to e2 this all makes a lot of sense
i'm activating my pieces i'm creating a
lot of threats i'm attacking the bishop
on d2 and any sort of discovery check is
going to come on the board for example
if you try to go rook to d1 game is over
bishop to e3 discovery check i'm going
to pick one piece then i'm going to pick
the other piece and i'm going to be
three pawns up that's enough for a
victory for black so you have to be very
careful right now as white and it seems
like one of the only moves would be to
go knight to f1
but that leads us to this position rook
takes d2 by the way also forced king
takes e3 rook takes b2 this is clearly a
winning position for black i just simply
or
at least a better position for black if
not winning i have four pawns that's a
lot of pawns
so per piece after rook to d2 knight xd2
bishop to d2 and i was looking at this
position i do have three pawns for an
exchange it feels like black is the one
playing for a victory the computer is
saying zero zero zero of course
but from a practical perspective
it does feel like black has the better
chances i was making normal moves rook
to d1 right attacking the bishop on d2
putting the rook on an open file black
is already much better after bishop to
g5 i'm going to cover all your entry
squares your rook is going to be
immobile on the d file you don't have
any ways in which you can create any
sort of unpleasant trees against my king
or any of the pawns on the queen side
because that would be your focus if you
can get to the pawns on the queen side
especially this pawn on b7 with a rook
landing on d on b8 that would be a key
to a victory for white you're not going
to get there because the only way
together is via d8 and that is covered
i'm going to slowly push my pawns and i
mean
this is looking pretty bad for white so
what did lanier
prepare prepare at home starting all the
way to this position because it just
seems that if black would have taken on
h2 instead of playing the move knight to
e3 which was played in the game by the
way it does look more natural to go
knight to e3 and try to grab this bishop
on d2 but it doesn't seem that after
knight to g5 queen takes g5
queen takes f2
i don't feel like white of course not
this was not played rook to e1 or or any
of uh that uh it seems like bishop f7 is
on the board right
this might just be uh
a draw right now because it feel of
course you're not going to take on f7
that's going to drop the rook and that
would be resign on the spot but i can
just simply attack the queen and it
seems like we're going to get
attack attack perpetual
how many minutes did lanier think for
bishop takes f7 one hour and 24 minutes
and after bishop to f7 one hour and five
minutes big decision bilinear and it
seems like this game is heading towards
a repetition we're going to see a draw
on this one i feel like linear had the
option of continuing the game with rook
to d1 keeping pieces on the board not
allow black to find this repetition and
i have a feeling from a practical
perspective at least white is slightly
better and in case of a draw christian
what will happen to this match for
tomorrow's well tomorrow is shankland
who has the white pieces and once again
we're going to see a theoretical battle
because this is exactly what happens
when these two players are facing each
other they're going to play 20 30 moves
of theory
and then at some point something is
going to crack and if nothing cracks
then they're going to move on to the
playoffs uh tomorrow night
one final thought i mean what we've seen
in this game to my eyes at least looks
like very correct chess it almost feels
like this game has been played before it
hasn't
has there been
a precedent game for
uh gameplay but it does seem like queen
f5 was never played before bishop to d1
and you had a very good memory uh there
alejandro it is a game between firuja
and kari akin and after bishop to d1 you
showed already this line it leads to
ignite c5 probably a slightly better end
game for white but it does seem like
black has enough resources to find uh
equality but he played the move queen to
f5 shanklin that is of course lanier was
aware of the existence of this move
queen to f5
and i mean it's the correct result we're
probably going to see a draw in this
game
chess correct chess it seems like there
is no real choice here for shanklin
either we can come back to that position
because as christian was mentioning you
have to do something here as black
you've given up the spot on f7 you
cannot capture the bishop uh immediately
because the rook on e3 is hanging so the
rook on
the rook has to attack the queen there's
nothing else there's no real advantage
of throwing in the check now that i can
see at least
there no i just seems very unnatural so
you start with the move rookie too
exactly you attack the queen the queen
doesn't have the many options and the
queen has to
keep a contact
with uh the bishop end or the rook uh
queen f3 seems the most natural but is
queen f1 legal i mean f1 is certainly
legal but it's no in no way an
improvement because i can always go
queen e4 check exactly and again i can't
trade queens because the bishop is
hanging so i have to move my king
and on your space scenario just to check
but i would be wondering if i can win
with group cafes
you start to say hey wait a minute i
think you're the one who messed up so we
are expecting rook e2 queen to f3 and
then as christian was mentioning we can
just go back and forth right with this
uh the game that is really looking like
it is heating up as wesley
wesley so versus sam sevillan when we
left it
wesley had a decision to make after the
move a7 a6 we thought g2 g4 had just
blast open
i think wesley didn't spend that much
time
before reaching for his g
coupon playing the move g4 and saying he
actually thought for 23 minutes oh he
did yeah
oh boy
okay i see the clock now maybe when i
looked at it it hadn't updated 107 so 23
minutes and after take takes
h5 h5 you want an exchange
come get it yeah you're welcome to come
and get it wow f2 h6 and maybe bishop h7
check in order to capture on g7 with
check sam said uh i'm not that greedy i
will uh drop back with my knight knight
f8 on the board and we have caught up
with the players uh
that black king how are we going to get
to it i mean you start you start by
bringing a rook right it's hard not to
play the move rook dg1 i do have
understand that
knight f2 is always such a threat i
don't want to give up my to court bishop
you're worried about the light square
you're not really
worried about your rook you're just
worried about your light squared bishop
so for example your fear is that after
move like h6 you're ready to sacrifice
like that on g6 right except you might
take your bishop yeah
as a prelim as a prelim move before
knight takes queen takes and then g6 and
g6 and you're not
being allowed to play the move bishop g6
which is what you wanted right so we go
back to this position and we say maybe
there's a better move here maybe a start
with the move h6 that was my question
right we start with h6 and the idea is
that if you go g6 now actually i don't
see another move uh rogue dg1 okay i'm
not threading the knight so it's not
like you have to move the knight from g4
but the point is that if you go the move
knight f2 i can start considering the
move bishop g6 now does this work
you know that's one of the things that i
even stopped analyzing at a certain
point you just feel like it works it
works it has to right right it just has
to and then you're absolutely gobsmacked
when it doesn't
how can it work it works uh but go back
one move yes c4 and you can resign
c4 and i can reset the game
spoken like the man with the chess edge
in the back correct that is very correct
and we will not take the challenge in
that case okay which means
that after knight f8
uh wesley's looking at a challenge
because like you say there is the move
c4
is on tap
it's such a complicated position
i was looking through the lines i
actually i'm pretty sure i've analyzed
this position this specific position in
preparation for uh some of my students
games
and i do remember that to be honest i
did not understand anything and my notes
i was like
played if you need to gamble don't play
play something much more uh safe as
white if you need uh to just get a
normal game because this is not a normal
game right now if you miss a beat you're
going to lose with both white and black
so
you have the right instinct alejandro h6
is the right move at the first because
what you're trying to do is actually
weaken the square f6 after g6 now
finally you can take on d5 of course you
can take on d5 even here yes so after
instead of h5 we were looking
at knight takes d5 knight to f2 and now
we're going to get this type of crazy
position in which white sacrificed an
exchange but of course uh the attack
continues and who knows what's going to
happen whoever has the better engine
whoever remembers
better the engine moves from home is
probably going to win this game it's a
double-edged sword
instead of that he played move h5 knight
to f8 and now as i was mentioning you
have this extra tool at your disposal as
white you can weaken the square f6 and
after g6 you can take on d5 now knight
to f2 is no longer possible because
right now with the weakness on f6 there
i'm just simply going to sidestep go
rook d to f1 and you no longer have time
well you can indeed take on h1 but after
knight to f6 is just simply going to be
a dominating position for white king to
h8 i'm going to take your rook you're
going to take my knight i'm going to
take your knight and that's just going
to be a much better position for white
if not winning already at this point at
least from a practical perspective but
of course
after knight to d5 you also have to
worry about the fact that
you're missing some bits and you're
giving your opponent uh the chance to
attack your pieces to take the
initiative take the tempo with the move
bishop to e6 attacking the knight now
you have to uh deal with where are you
going to put the knight are you going to
try to cover up with knight to c3
because you know something is going to
land on c8 and open up the c file the
position is going to get wild after
bishop to e6 it seems like according to
the engine at least whites still have an
edge after knight to f4 but look i'm
seeing this position on the board
and to be honest i don't understand
anything and the guy has an engine
without the engine this is because look
after bishop to f4 the best move is to
go h7 first
who knows why wow h7 first and it seems
like this one leads to a better position
for uh
white after c takes d4 just simply take
on d4 and the fact that you're going to
get this bishop to c3 and you have the
king on h8 right now so now i understand
this move h7 forced the king to go to h8
so my bishop on c3 is going to have a
clear task and that is to open up the
diagonal and checkmate you now with
the king on g8 i would assume the idea
is that if you take immediately i'm
going to be able to take on d4 and then
cover with the move knight to h7
preserve the king on g8 not on a dark
square and then the bishop on c3 is not
going to be as useful that's just a
guess that's a wild guess this is a wild
game
take it uh take it away and analyze it
[Laughter]
i was ready to sacrifice uh smack on a
g7 in that line where you put your
knight on h7
uh yeah that that that is really really
really uh a tough one let me just jump
in on the game of lavon and ray robson
because i
yes we did see the knight coming back to
the a4 square because i was very curious
whether lavon
you know sometimes you know you see that
night on a4 and you just think to
yourself well
man you're just out of civilization
you're just living on a
your own little desert island away from
uh
anything and after bishop d7 but maybe
what uh christians suggested c5 knight
c4
maybe planting a knight on b6
we're still playing
for an advantage i was
these are the type of positions that
when black starts to get the initiative
then it really rolls very well for black
um c5 c5 is the most natural move but as
we're talking about it i see that i
won't actually play the movie knight b3
wow
interesting reinforcing this knight
tango over there in the queen side is
fascinating it seems like the knights
are being placed in worse and worse
positions but he must have something
very specific for the moment
i am curious if bishop takes c6 as a
threat sometimes you don't want to do it
because it does cost you like quote
dragon bishop right but it is an
important pawn yeah d4 is a central pawn
it's a crucial part of black's position
so bishop c6 does look like it's a
threat not an easy one to parry because
there's a couple of problems that move
knight b3 doesn't only threaten bishop
take c6 it also hints at the fact that a
knight i'm not sure which knight yeah
maybe the b3 maybe a b knight a4 knight
yeah we'll land on c5 pressure the d7
bishop pressure the b7 pawn prepare the
move b4 behind it
and then you can again more or less see
how white's position rolls forward
it's like
strange a lot of black's pieces are like
gummy
you know they're not on their ideal
squares now having said that
i do
i'm the pawn grubber in the family over
here so i i i do think that bishop c6
might be the kind of move that is a
threat uh let me just put something
just
yeah
very
defend the pawn on d4 bishop takes e6
will now be met with bishop take c6 and
the pawn on d4 is defended and i think
if you do make the match i think we have
to yeah move knight c5 that was why i
used the a rook not necessarily the f
rook i put my bishop back to c8 defend
the pawn on b7 and go ahead and say you
know do your worst on the queen side
rook b1 yeah maybe rook b1 or queen d2
both moves with the idea of preparing
the move b4 exactly and then trying to
say b4 b5 is coming uh what do you have
against it right
very nice okay well this is a game that
really
is i love it it's a a battle of ideas
right a strategic idea battle of ideas
here in this position but we have a
tweet from one of our audiences let's
take a look at what's the first question
of the tournament is
the american cup will christian and
alejandra be part of fabi's team for the
candidates ratnesh wants to know radnesh
806 wants to know
and i will answer for fabby he's going
to keep it right no no but he's not
going to get an answer i know the answer
because i was at dinner with fabi and he
was very very specific he said you never
tell who your seconds are because it
gives information to your opponents
uh if if you are on the team your
opponent will look up what are your
specialties what are you going to be
teaching
um fabi so fabi's not saying and neither
are these guys well it'll be a surprise
to come madrid in the candidates but if
i have a one-way ticket to spain arena
why not there's a lot of things there
yeah you need anybody to
anybody to handle your luggage for you
you know
set you in somebody needs to be the bell
boy exactly
well uh but thank you for the question
of course the candidates coming up in
madrid in june yes and we're going to be
having it'll be starting in
june 17th
and we will have a one american in this
event
fabiano uh
and sorry two americans andy karnakan
were that just qualified over the grand
prix route right and
it is a very outside chance that dingle
dingleran doesn't make it but we do
expect dinglerank to be uh the final
player of the candidates
but in case he's not who would be he'll
be levon
i believe that lebronronian is ahead of
wesley in raiding right now it comes
down to the may
edition of the raiding list i believe
that levon is ahead of him i don't know
if this tournament will count towards it
it might well this tournament finishes
on the 29th 29th so
it's a key tournament definitely to that
where's your final attorney when you
need help right
wow
it really comes down to that well
we do expect that dingley ryan will
finish the requirements that he will
need to be in the number of games
required now the question is whether
fida is going to allow that because we
know that ding has been playing 30 plus
games in one month a quadruple
robin in china
all the games played in china
and i think this is a very important
ding is a marvelous player he deserves
to be in the candidates but it's not a
discussion the discussion is about like
i want to become a grand master i'm
trying to get my norms but i can't play
just against my fellow countrymen
i have to have a certain number of
foreign players foreign grand masters
four and ion and so on and he's playing
games in china with all chinese players
and it looks like an arranged tournament
it doesn't feel good it doesn't look
good
yeah we've had a lot of problems
especially with the chinese players they
have a particular situation with kobe it
is very difficult for them to travel
mandatory quarantine still coming back
to china not just two weeks it's
actually a three-week quarantine coming
back
and that makes it exceedingly difficult
for them to travel that being said of
course the such a late announcement that
they would use only one installment of
the rating list to determine who
qualifies to the candidates and the fact
that they brought back the reigning spot
uh for the tournament after getting rid
of it and that was fabby's spot too at
the time
that forced him fabi to play in the uh
swiss right and of course we're talking
about all of these things because of the
ban on sergey karjakin because it was
all pretty much said and done it was
pretty much going to be that gay was
going to play he was going to play
joined by the last two players that
qualified from the grand prix and it
feels like very last minute the entire
system was changed and things fell
through the crack right as anushkiri
pointed out he wasn't thinking about the
rating because that spot was taken away
and he would have thought differently
about his schedule of tournaments had a
rating spot
been available especially after fabi
qualified directly from the grand swiss
so a last minute uh amount of chaos
absolutely
is uh going to determine the uh
the uh
candidates and then the challenger yes
and it's going to be a fun event uh i
think it's a spectacular candidate that
we're going to be seeing uh fabio of
course being there laresa such a young
age dingle iran going to be there such a
strong chair
everybody that's make that makes up the
rest of the tournament i think is very
dangerous very tricky richard report
fantastic fantastic player hikaru
nakamura has shown incredible nerves
incredible willpower not just as a
streamer but as a chess player and as a
wild card entrance too he ends up
winning the grand prix that's what
though and easily right right not even
close wow so it's going to be a fun
candidate so i'm very excited about it
uh probably two americans in it and
we'll see we'll see how they do even the
potential for a third
meanwhile and we do have sam shanklin i
guess lanier dominguez repeating in that
position but that's not much of a
surprise we did expect that
this has to more or less go that way i
don't see
a good position for that queen where i
can try to do
something clever right like a tactic
well let me try the clever how about
queen of five so the idea in this case
is that if you
play rook to e5
yes i was going to grab a pawn queen
takes the idea is you can't take with
the queen because i do have rook f1 i'm
a little bit afraid of rook e1 check
though
uh
why couldn't i take the the the bishop
directly the last move out of curiosity
i'm sorry
like the rook's on e3
oh that's right
they have to keep connection with the
rook i have to keep connecting because
you have to check on c5 but i also have
queen e7 which defends both nice but
maybe we can do your idea oops excuse me
this was uh queen to c5 check attacks
the rook and the king but queen e7 right
yes exactly queen to e7 blocks the check
defends the rook and sidesteps
my idea of rook f1 but maybe your idea
we can implement it with the movies
queen f4 first okay ah
learning
the rook come here to e4 where i can
keep an eye on you that's right and then
play the move queen f5 maybe
now
no you don't have green f7 because i
just take on e4 and then maybe in here i
do have to look at the move
between eight okay so five and rookie
one and now the question is if you have
any ideas after knight to f1 you don't
have time to take the rook on a1 because
queen g8 is a mate
but
if i just simply take on f7 with the
king
do you have a way to give a double
double attack find the double attack
against my rook on e1
don't say sign soon
you have a check and i hide on g8 and
that's it and i think i think you have
one check actually
and then knight on b6 which is useless
isn't it absolutely
it's funny let's put that on the
position right queen five check king g8
and it looks like queen c8 is a check
but no there's a knight on v6
and queen d5 looks like a check but no
there's a knight on v6 the hero who's
done nothing the entire game suddenly uh
covers uh both checks so they're
really from lanier's point of view if
there's no queen
f4 queen f5 takes h7 ideas then it looks
like an insert appropriate one last look
no i have to maintain you have to
maintain connection with the rook is the
problem
i can't play queen f1 you cannot play
queen f1 no nope
so uh we do expect a uh draw on that
game fabi uh with the game of
jeffrey uh
fabi has the
open e file it looks like
he's he's played knight g5 provoked the
move g6 and he's followed up with bishop
e5
uh it looks to me like he's got the
initiative for free he has the much
easier play in the position but that
doesn't mean
that jeffrey's without chances yeah this
is the typical position in which black
is not afraid to play two result game
it's not like black is counter attacking
at any point they're fine being passive
they're pi they're fine playing for a
draw very common scenario in tournament
that's a knockout you want to draw with
blackwood with white exactly and i agree
with you wholeheartedly uh
fabi seems to have gotten a little bit
of a better position against jeffrey
we're mentioning earlier that the move
rook b1 was completely superfluous in
many lines this definitely is one of
them yeah what would the rook have been
doing on b1 put it on e1 put it in the
open file where it's actually threading
more things and after a6 played after a
long think actually h3 bishop d6 knight
g5 g6 when they move bishop e5
black's still under pressure i'm not
really sure what the threat is
right i was wondering if i'm going to
play f4 or
something like that and make these
pretensions of playing for f5 but yes
that is the question is what is my
threat and what i mean to say that it's
not as if black is just you know like
over being overwhelmed or anything like
this yes i do understand the move e6
might be all very well and good but for
the moment there's no real weaknesses in
black's camp
maybe c4
it doesn't look a little sketchy though
right
allowing e6 and knight coming to e6
right yes
it could be that uh the move knight e5
isn't that desirable maybe then i have
to drop back with the bishop right away
i'm just saying that uh
it
it's by no means overwhelming it's not
obviously overwhelming it shouldn't be
but there's a lot of tricks i want to
point out the bishop fade i i i see
immediately
immediately okay and i want to see if
this trick works for me please i was
thinking can i play queen g3
c7 now i understand you could take on e5
but i'm happy if you take because i'll
take back with the pawn and you cannot
prevent
e6 okay let's let's work with the
assumption that's good for y you're
wonderful and you play something like
for example yeah i can take on h7 right
can you take on h7
it takes you have to take back because
knight f6 is such a huge threat right
queen h4 check
bishop only move h6 of queen h8 mate
requires me to play this and i think i
have bishop f4
and i pick up the bishop with check in
almost every variation
no question about it there's no there's
no time for the defensive move g5 either
yes
so that's the tactic so some ideas right
the white is trying to figure out what
at what point can i track my opponent
right have this little bit of pressure
capitalize into something
and i think this is kind of the point
right if you go bishop f8 maybe queen g3
because white only has a couple of moves
if you play bishop f fade and then you
kick me out with h6
or that and or bishop h6 yeah that's it
yeah that's the end of the initiative
then it's it's just a stop so queen g3
reinforcing some trickies
you're saying once again that knight
takes e5 pawn takes e5 yes the move e6
so if i go bishop g7 this is the idea
the
the the knight is very very powerful on
e6
i'm not saying i'm winning but it looks
a bit dangerous knight takes c7 maybe
knight c5 maybe maybe he'll take the
bishop on g7
it takes a while to warm up to white's
position but in fact yeah white's not in
any dangers
and
back over to you christian what do you
have for us in the ladies section one
player that is definitely capitalizing
on their opponent's mistakes is irena
crush the a-time national champion
because right now she's piling on the
pressure on her younger opponent after
knight to e4 this is the position we
left it off and we were mentioning the
idea of uh bringing the bishop to d4
instead arena decided to maintain the
spin with the move a bishop to h4 and
now
it seems like rooyan just simply blinked
she lost the tempo with the move h6 it
does feel like a correct move you're
trying to potentially have this idea of
g5 harass the bishop on this diagonal
potentially lengthen uh the diagonal of
your bishop after knight to d4 to be
able to retreat to h7 it seems like a
normal move right but unfortunately
you're just simply losing a tempo and
after knight to d4 bishop to h7 i'm
going to snack on that pawn on b7 yes
please give me that pawn you can take
the pawn on c3 that is my weakness i'm
not taking your weakness i'm not
exchanging weakness for weakness i'm
exchanging a very good pawn the pawn on
b7 for the pawn on c3 which probably
would have fallen anyway and we're going
to be uh left with a position such as
after castle probably we're going to
take on c3 but now we're going to be
fighting
white's position
two bishops very healthy structure
absolutely no problems with her king and
black uh in return has a big weakness
all of his uh pieces seems to be
discombobulated the knight on c3 knight
on f6 bishop on h7 it doesn't look good
it doesn't feel natural for uh black and
it just feels like white has full
control over the position you can play
bishop to f3 you can get fancy with
moves uh
such as bishop to a6 which is proposed
by the engine i don't think she's going
to go to a6 of course it looks a bit
strange but bishop to f3 just normal
move and you're going to enjoy this very
long term initiative against the pawn on
d5 and with the bishop er it seems like
definitely irena crush is getting the
position that she wants in uh this
particular matchup and another
interesting game that's been developing
is this one between nemtsova and tokyo
nova let's remind our viewers that these
two players have identical rating 23
35 both of these players
bishop to f5 was played this is where we
left it and a3 was played because of
course with this move bishop to f5
you're signaling that you want to go
potentially knight to b4 and take
advantage of this light squares
light square on c2 d3 potentially if you
go
c4 if you hurry the move c4 as white so
you're just taking away with this move
a3 uh the jump on b4 knight to e4 c4 but
this weakens this complex of pawns on
the light squares b3 and c4 weakened by
this move a3 as well and she's and by
the way we do have a handshake in the
game between dominguez and shanklin we
were mentioning at the beginning of the
broadcast that this one is going to be a
very tense battle between close
competitors and this is exactly what
we're seeing a draw has been agreed
and too fast and just to finish the
thought uh in uh that game between
tahiti nova and so after knight to f5
you're starting to see that you have
clear problems with these two pawns
these two weaknesses the pawn on b3 and
on c4 one way you can defend that is the
move that was played in the game queen
to e3 of course you're defending the
bishop uh the pawn on b3 the problem is
you're also allowing black to continue
attacking that complex of pawns with the
move bishop to c2 which was not spotted
by tokyo genova this move bishop to c2
would have given her a clear advantage
now white has to find all sorts of
gymnastics in the position you have to
go bishop to
c3 allow black to go knight to b3 and
now try to take advantage of the fact
that the knight is on the b fire with
the move rook to a2
not very natural right bishop to f5 then
rook to b2 you're still worse you're
going to be a pawn down and it doesn't
seem like you're going to recover
anytime soon instead of that
tokyo nova play this move queen to b6
with the same idea attacking the pawn on
b3 but white had a very smart way to
defend against that with the move bishop
to c3 take advantage of the fact that if
you decide to take on b3 well that's a
problem because i'm going to sacrifice
the exchange you can take it take it but
how are you going to deal with this a
big pin very difficult to uh get rid of
on the b file it does seem like white is
gaining the initiative in this position
instead of that after queen to b6 it
seems like so i played the move
knight to d2
which
i'm not so sure about because what if i
just simply take on c4 of course you can
take with the knight on c4 but what if i
just simply take on b3 now
i guess you want to stick with the
bishop on c4 she does what i'm in love
with this
she does want to take with the bishop on
c4 but now okay you defended one
weakness how are you going to defend the
other one
i'm just going to go to d8 attack the
pawn on d4 open up the position
everything's weak everything is weak uh
and maybe you can take on e7 but knight
c4 i take c4 is a big problem yeah
because right now you cannot take with
the b pawn of course the bishop b2 is
hanging you'd have to take but
this is the problem you're releasing the
defense on the pawn on b3 with this
queen moving to e7 now it's a problem
because you're going to defend sure
we're going to exchange and we're going
to uh end up in an end game in which i
have a clear advantage first of all i'm
just simply a pawn up but uh also you
cannot take on a7 this bishop on d4 is
nicely defining it seems like
the tactics work in black's favor
exactly knight to d2 is on the board 42
minutes for nemtsova tohir jonova with
50 minutes and once again i'm going to
throw it to you alejandro because this
is your student yeah so i want you to
tell me what's happening in this one
what i'm saying is the time situation 28
minutes for uh minutes for so lucky to
do one hour and eight minutes for alice
lee what is your take coach i mean i see
this monster night on d5 and i get very
worried exactly it's such a beautiful
piece and it feels like black got
everything she wanted out of the opening
we could switch uh to that position with
the knight on d5
between the last move that alice just
made by the way this move bishop e7 to
f8 this is like such a karpovian-like
move the bishop on f8 just stops any
ideas of bishop takes h6 which the move
queen c c one was clearly directed at
white was
ready to invest a bishop uh with a
bishop sacrifice but bishop f8 is just
put the kibosh on that and this position
looks very good for black it looks like
a very simple plan you somehow defend
upon c4 push b4
and then just keep them keep pushing
them keep pushing yeah this seems very
very bad here for uh my students to rule
out but we'll see if she can recover
also not very pretty on the clock
uh but we do have a guest with us the
first result of the american cup 2022
was a draw between linear dominguez and
sam shankar with absolutely furious
theory we have sam shanklin himself
former u.s champion with us uh let's
take a look at what happened in your
game sam
sam first of all uh tell us a little bit
about the format of this event is very
new and exciting what how do you feel
about it um so of course if you ask like
20 different players what their favorite
format would be you get 20 different
answers and while
if i just got to pick exactly the format
myself and then i got to play the
tournament that's not a luxury anyone
ever gets but if i got to pick it this
is not what it would be but it's darn
close
it's closer than anything i've seen and
so i'm a huge proponent of knockout
tournaments
i think the by far the most successful
individual sport is tennis and while not
a huge tennis fan as far as i know
essentially every single serious tennis
tournament is knockout and uh i think
it's a fantastic format and i'm really
happy to be finally playing a big
knockout event with some best players
all over the world from here in st louis
and tell us a little bit about this
specific matchup between you and
dominguez every single game you guys are
playing it seems like it goes on a long
theoretical battle 20 30 moves of theory
how did you approach this match yeah so
i mean i had a little bit of time to
prepare for him so i think probably the
format doesn't suit him as well just
because he's um he seems like crazy well
prepared and just plays his normal stuff
and says come at me find the best stuff
you have and
if you have 24 hours to prepare for him
uh it's pretty real chance he's just
going to prepare you but
even if he just plays his normal
repertoire but if you have two weeks
it's a little different
um no i mean i
i got more of a sense of him as a player
i i've learned a lot by losing to him in
us championship when i
got some slightly better position with
white i saw tons of end games that were
slightly better and thought basically
black is holding them and eventually one
off the deep end just went too crazy
trying to kill him and then when he drew
his other 10 games in the tournament i
felt like an idiot but um
no i think i have a better sense of him
now um but
it's one thing to have a better sense if
i played something to beat him he's
obviously very strong and so you know
we'll see let's take a look at the game
tell us uh when did your preparation
finish
um so i i definitely had bishop d2 but i
i wasn't remembering everything uh super
clear i thought i remember thinking
bishop g5 was
the most testing of after um
after king f8 i remembered i definitely
reviewed bishop g5 this morning and i
know i have analyzed bishop d2 yeah so
here queen e2 king f8 i'm pretty sure
bishop g5 is most testing i reviewed
that this morning but
i i know i covered bishop d2 but i
couldn't remember very well so
uh after i'm pretty i'm 90 sure knight
g4 is right maybe even 95 percent
because i i remembered after queen f1
knight e3
take
actually in this position i think knight
x h2 was recommended uh by the engine
going into the line of knight xh2 take
on h2 rook to e5 or look to e4
i saw this as well but i thought that
knight e3 was
i'm pretty sure i had knight e3 as well
as as equalizing um
but so he took it rook e3 and i know
that for example rook d1 is a draw after
rook f3 and knight f3 and queen g2 queen
h2 forever so um
but yeah knight g5 came and i was a bit
foggy on the details i'm actually pretty
sure what i played does not equalize
that i remember thinking that this
uh queen take queenie stuff this rook
this queen takes g5 and and queen e7 was
not supposed to equalize but i was
shocked by bishop takes f7 i thought
here absolutely everything was a draw
like i just couldn't find a way for me
to even screw it up after the g5
queen e7 bishop f7 like i was also
thinking like if i go queenie for check
and then he goes king g1 and rookie two
i guess the big point was bishop d5
chuck
uh and after this
rook f2 bishop v4 rook b2 i still
thought this was almost certainly drawn
after say like i thought like i don't
know bishop b7 rook c2 or something and
he's you cannot possibly tell me he's
gonna beat me with his rook on a3 like i
i thought this was basically a draw and
then also after rookie two queen f3
i thought rook takes h2 was a draw as
well so
uh
i i didn't think i would lose this end
game after king h2 queen f7 so i thought
absolutely everything was a draw my sis
i think the rookie three is most direct
there was just one detail that um
was important to see that there was this
funny line that if we go queen f4 maybe
i can even play g5 but i was thinking
rookie four five point five rookie five
queen h7 and here i was calculating some
nonsense where i go king f7 rook f1 king
e6 and ron and i didn't see a win for
him even there but there's this nice
idea i can go rookie one check
knight f1 and then king takes f7 and
this move order he doesn't even get any
checks in here probably white is worse
because he runs out of checks after say
queen f5 king g aiden
so as far as i can tell it's just a dead
draw after bishop takes f7 i think you
should have tried rook g1 but this just
seemed very easy
sam thank you very much tomorrow with
the white pieces we're looking forward
to that game i'll do my best
thank you sam
absolutely a theoretical duel we
expected that from these two players
incredibly well prepared both of them
and and they show their stuff i mean
perfect game what can we say yeah good
chess good chest absolutely good trust
uh let's take a look at the wesley game
because let's face it this is what's
going to be keeping our attention
because our things are flying there's a
pawn sacrifice now with this knight
takes g4 wesley decided to go h59 f8 and
immediately rook dg1 we're considering
imposes on minuses of going h6 first but
he's going to throw rook dg1 on the
board immediately
yeah we were definitely of the
persuasion of h6 right and then it was
kind of tricky because it was like h6 g6
knight takes d5
d5 you're encouraging this weakness on
the f6 square but rugged gg1 was played
knight f2 attacking the h1 rook also
hitting the bishop on d3 which is an
important attacker and this is where we
are right now wesley
not a deep think but in a think at the
moment yeah and here we kind of stopped
after say h6 and not g6 allowing the
move bishop takes g6 which by the way we
never really we just said and
whatever yeah but we were afraid of
knight takes d3 queen takes d3 and now
g6 but we could even
have continued the line from here uh
it's super sharp but once again we have
a special guest in studio alejandro all
right uh drawing with the white pieces
linear dominguez is with christian thank
you alejandro yes we are indeed with
lanier dominguez linear every time i see
you play against shanklin it's just this
crazy theoretical battle did you expect
that training for this game
not really i wasn't expecting the line
with d5
i thought sam was playing mainly with d6
before this game
but it's of course a very direct line
very critical i was trying to remember
this line that we played because this
rook a8 is
pretty much the best move in this
position and and
i
i was analyzing and i i thought i had
some line i mean i thought i looked at
some line where uh maybe in practice it
was a bit tricky for for black i don't
remember if it was bishop d2 what i
played or not i was
uh trying to remember during the game
but i i
i don't know if this felt like the first
critical moment bishop to d2 or bishop
to g5 yeah i remember that b75 being
knight g4 uh and and then uh queen c
bishop c5 being
been the one of the main lines but
yeah i remember that there were a couple
of possible ways for white to play
and uh
and yeah bishop d2 seems
seems like
like a possible option yeah here i think
uh yeah after knight g4
were you at uh at all concerned at this
point because he was just blitzing out
his moves he had one hour and 35 minutes
at some point and you only had one hour
in 20 minutes it felt like you were the
one that were surprised in this game
yeah no as i said i knew the line uh
that that's why i wasn't like overly
concerned i know that white is uh not
lost yet but
but uh yeah
obviously he he knew the line well
and um that's why i didn't want to go
for b5 because i know it was supposed to
be the main line i was trying to find
something else
but yeah unfortunately this uh after
bishop d2 knight g4 it's very logical
queen f1 and this knight e3 it's a
it's probably okay for black i know that
knight takes h2 and rook e5 or even rook
e5 immediately it's should make a draw
yeah it's a draw by force but
it's maybe less obvious if you are let's
say playing over the world
uh but yeah after 93 takes takes knight
g5
uh
queen takes
takes on f2 and this queen is seven it's
important move because if you play
rookie 7 rook f1 then it's a little bit
unpleasant
but
but after queen e7 unfortunately
i didn't see much because just i mean if
rook f1
black and played guinea four but also f6
yeah
it's very simple at this point you did
understand that bishop takes f7 just
forces a draw right that was a big
decision uh did you consider other moves
such as rook to d1 or f1 try to keep the
game going and how did you uh decide on
bishop takes f7 and pretty much kill the
game yeah i thought that uh black is
doing really well like in in the long
term it can be
dangerous for dangerous for white
because uh three pawns i mean if we were
to trade queens or something then i
definitely would take black
and
then also if i try to keep the queens my
king is always i mean he will always get
counter play with queen e4 check so i
don't really believe that
i had anything at this point that's why
i went for for bishop takes f7 and i
think objectively it's probably the
uh
decision
thank you very much and uh good luck in
tomorrow's game you're playing the black
pieces how are you going to approach
that game
yeah i mean it's uh just uh just normal
i mean clearly tomorrow it's a
much more important date than today
we'll decide the match
but uh yeah i'll just
looking forward to not only the game of
tomorrow but just the rest of the
tournament looking forward to seeing you
in action good luck and see you tomorrow
thank you
good luck lanier and here we have our
result our first result
of american cup 2002 2022 sorry
2002. let's take a look at what we have
uh especially interesting games in the
uh open championship bracket let's take
a look at what happened in the ironian
game against ray robson absolutely yes
uh ray decided to sacrifice a pawn he
didn't go for the rook d8
move just to defend the pawn on d4
instead he said b7 b6 i'm going to deny
you
this square c5 for your knight
and are you really going to give up as
you said this beautiful dragon bishop
for a lousy pawn and he said yeah yeah
of course let me let me take that pawn
bishop take c6 was played by uh lavon
and after bishop takes c6
knight takes d4 there's the pawn and i
really like this from rey that he gave
himself a square on b7 with the move b6
it not only prevented the move knight c5
but also now that the knight takes on d4
the bishop remains on this long open
beautiful diagonal by having the b7
square
and one of the benefits of that and
normally speaking when you're you have
this setup of two knights versus two
bishops uh the player with the knight
is is trying to get rid of one of the
bishops so we do see the move knight b5
and by the way the knight on b5 on d4
was kind of
in mid-air so moving the knight out of
the square d4 ii will protect the square
and at the same time by the way i am a
pawn up and therefore i do start
thinking about playing the moves d4 d5
try to shut down the bishop compensation
for the pawn yeah we'll say that we'll
say that
but is it enough is it enough that's a
real question right you have a knight on
a4 that's not doing very much for your
position that bishop on b7 is just a
permanently a beautiful piece but i'm
two moves away from d4 d5 and d45 comes
on the board it shuts down the bishop on
b7 it creates problems on e6 suddenly
those bishops don't look so beautiful i
think there's enough compensation for
this pawn but i think that ray has to be
extremely precise in the next couple of
moves christian your perspective on this
pawn sacrifice by ray uh what a
practical point of view we're going to
get that one in a second but i have a
challenge for you guys
we're going to jump straight into a
segment that we introduced during the us
chess championships and uh maurice was
at the board back then he was kind of
beating us i'm talking about human
versus machine okay so let's get going
and i'm actually going to put a lot of
pressure on you
with this game between wesley soh
and sam savion okay wesley just played
the move d takes c5
after knight to f2
immediately sam responded with bishop to
e5 all right
try to play
i'm going to play as white got it i'm
going to go off h6
you guys are going to be with the black
pieces and try to defend this monstrous
attack coming
up yeah
but if it's going to be a human versus
machine i'm looking and i'm seeing a
shadow on your board telling me what to
do that's pretty easy
to go g6
don't look at it don't look
[Laughter]
okay
i'm going to give you a check
well gee
i wonder what i'm playing on this one
i'm not going to touch that you don't
want to take it i don't want to take it
watch right no i gotta get it i got it
bishop g6 i got to put my king in the
corner yeah okay king h all right all
right
all right now turn off the engine yeah
good luck okay so the point is no more
no more directions for you yeah no more
shadow
boxing here
okay so the point is if we try to put
the desirable bishop g7 on the board to
take his rook we're hanging d5 but
that's not the end of the story either
but in any case i'm really not even sure
what the threats are
i
so i start to look at bishop g4 right
why not
all right bishop g4 looks like then he
could play like rook's e5 rookie five
and how is he gonna put his bishop on c3
i don't know
[Applause]
talking with alejandra don't be pushing
it is that
before
you don't see anything wrong with it
i mean it's got to be something like
rookie five rookie five night but what
do i do with this knight on c3 exactly
and then you know then you're gonna go
knight f4 with the bishop on g4
then you go to knight f4 and then you're
going to go knight d5
okay we're going to we're going to go
down in the blaze again
let's do it bishop g4 bishop to g4 we're
going to go down in the blaze of glory
excellent
rookie five
it's gotta be rookie five yeah did he
play rook okay
i take it all right hold the thing back
oh
is there any reason we should no the
bishop is not going anywhere right we
can take our move back okay rook takes
e5 right
knight f4 is what i'm afraid
bishop e1
no i was not afraid of this
well it's attacking the night i don't
have a lot of options here i take on i
take on d3 right we yes we have a
consensus there yes i'm not even going
to use the engine for this one thank you
good job
grand master title it's not human versus
machine after all okay so you just got a
queen on d4 and you're saying life is
good
is it i don't know how good is it i put
my picture first five and go f6 very
greedy
yes uh there's also maybe some reasons
that you might want to be able to put
your rook on h5
or queen to e7 how bad is bishop takes
e2 and queen e7 no but then bishop c3
right oh you're going to
you're going to recapture with the with
the uh
with the knight yeah
yeah okay alejandro liked bishop f5
let's do it bishop f5 bishop to f5 queen
to d4 f6 yeah f6 looks logical oh six is
forced f6 is four sources
f4 and this i i agree it's a very groovy
exchange you guys are doing great by the
way
thank you i'm impressed yeah
the man is impressed we can play chess
i think it might be time to take take
this h7 pawn off the board i'm not sure
wow with king takes that's yeah that's
scary though
or you wanted to bring the rook on a8
into the game get something counter
queen maybe queen eight or queen e7 well
queen e7 runs into taking on d5 with the
tempo which is why i wanted to play them
with queenie to sidestep it okay but
then knight dxd4 still knight takes d5
still i was thinking rook d8
how about that queen eight one night one
of the knight stakes on d5 we pin it
with rook d8 i'm not afraid of knight
takes f6 i'll take on d4
i'll take on the e8 then i might raise
the bishop c3 again there's bishop c3 at
the end yeah
we're waiting guys
my chess coach of the year i got i mean
how can i speak against all right
exactly it must be a great movie is it a
great move
not really
you don't say it's a bad move it's not a
bad move yes all right it doesn't lose
on the spot
wow
this is a this is damn
this is all the praise i expect nowadays
from my students from my co-host from my
friends it's illegal
it doesn't lose on the side
it only blundered upon
who cares um wow yeah why isn't g5 i'll
make it easy for you guys
survive for three more moves
damn is it that bad
come on g5 knight d5 knight knight h7
but he g5 he'll take him in g5
he'll take on g5
i don't know
don't ask me
oh probably he will okay so let's start
with knight h3
knight h7 yeah yeah h7 preparation
knight h7 that h7 is uh our answer
the answer is
what's wrong here
something g can i play g5 he's going to
play bishop g3 two more moves guys
he's gonna do it and and we got to deal
with knight c7 what about rook d8 here
okay rick died let's go for it
bishop f6
knight takes only move
there's a lot more than three moves by
the way hey
that's it that's it three moves i think
rook takes d4 well right what's the
evaluation at the end because i take on
d4
rook takes d4
he has
actually advantage after check
[Music]
and i take back on d4 i have the
connected passers pawn up
winning end game you guys didn't make it
machine wins
the guy is telling me to resign i'm
looking at this like a three years old
game i have a bat i have an active king
i have an active king i have a pawn on
g6 that's queening and the guy's telling
me yeah you might as well recently i
don't know our our television our live
television audience is all for alejandro
and myself in this particular case
i'm sorry for you christian
you're over
they're following potentially our line
no no they're not because he's allowing
bishop takes g6 check isn't he bishop
takes jesus oh we're thinking about that
but we kind of were lazy on it right
this is g6 this was what we looked at
we didn't age seven king h8 now we took
two three first
no
what no
we did we were taking on d3 because we
didn't want to allow white the bishop to
he played bishop g4 that's right he's
right who played rook h5 bishop g4 yeah
sorry you're right h7 this is the line
we followed king to ha the rook two h5
yeah yeah i don't think wesley is going
to play this move rook to h5 it doesn't
feel very natural bishop to g4 by the
way was a great move by you guys i was
considering bishop to g7 but then rook
takes d5 that was what i was afraid of
that's probably going to be a problem
long term right i'm just going to have
an advantage long term as white rook to
h5 is a difficult move to see bishop to
g4 rook takes e5 of course this is all
more or less forced take on d3 bishop
here's the question as well still good
go wrong still good still good because i
thought we were doing good you guys did
great so far so good right right knight
to f4 and this was the critical moment
we had to play knight e6 because we went
queen e8 yes you have to go for the
exchanges you have to simplify the
position and try to uh release some
tension from white's attack and that is
with the move knight to e6 that's fair
of course i understand that the position
still remains extremely complicated
after knight takes e6 rook takes 36 i
still have the dark square bishop if i
manage to land it anywhere on the long
diagonal and eliminate the pawn on f6
you still have a lot of problems to deal
with so after bishop to f4 you have to
go rook to c8
complicated position it remains a
complicated position uh black still has
to deal with a lot of things but it
seems it's a double-edged sword it's a
three game result and this is exactly
what both players seem to want in this
game
this one however
rook to h5 is not going to be an easy
move i'm not predicting the move rook to
h5 or wesley
but the alternative being another
alternative could be maybe h7 king to h8
but now you still have rook to h5 what
if you don't go rook to h5 what if you
try to play something like knight i
don't know chris you guys tell me
yeah
bishop g6 yeah if you put the party
before f6 yeah yeah i'm just going to
take it and rook takes and then king
goes actually i'm not not even king goes
i'm going to uh because
not only
i'm wondering if this is good yeah this
is a totally different line this is the
pony five guards g7 yes yeah king h8
wins as well knight takes g6 wins uh
with a larger margin uh
sacrifice doesn't work
um christian a question for you could
you take white's last two moves back in
just a moment yes
so
uh and d4 takes e5 as well if you could
take that move back
c5 was a bad move by the way and this is
why i wanted to challenge you because
after d takes c5 black is actually
better
really yes d65 bishop to e5 a great move
by sam and black right now is actually
in pole position white is the one
that needs to find the way through
wow so
without the move d takes e5 and if i
could just ask you this uh rook g1 and
if you take on h1 and if i go h6 and if
you go yes so what do you play right now
because he's white to move
h6 h6 okay and if you go g6
does bishop takes g6 win for white no no
loses
king h8 and still nothing yeah still
nothing yeah the knight on f8 controls
very nicely the score h7 and that is the
only transition squad towards the
checkmate because rook g7 queen to h7 is
the only threat that i can see in the
position right
you would like to get rid of the pawn h6
yeah take it away from
takes g7 impossible check right yeah
yeah
no it seems like black is just uh larson
fights off eight and i don't think it
made it no wow okay
so in fact the move d4 takes c5 by
wesley was ill-timed and it's like uh
wesley is the one uh
scrambling in this position which is
very surprising and it's it's such a
mess i wouldn't think during a game if
i'm scrambling or not just kind of
finding moves it's so difficult to
actually put an evaluation to this
position you don't just suddenly stop in
your mind and go oh my god oh my god and
that is exactly i i gotta parachute my
way out of it no you're just thinking
i'm attacking things will happen you're
not really sure you're not even down
material here are you and i told you
guys at the beginning of the broadcast i
looked at this specific position and i
said this is a gamble
no matter what the evaluation is
according to the engine even if it's
like plus 1.5 plus 0.7 it's a gamble you
play a normal move such as d takes c5
and suddenly you're worse remarkable so
if you want to take that gamble take it
i would probably not recommend it it
seemed like wesley felt comfortable in
this position maybe he analyzed it in
preparation for the grand prix because
we know the grand prix uh just happened
he probably had some residual uh
preparation from that event and maybe
felt comfortable in uh this melee but
right now after bishop to e5 h6 g6 on
the board is uh in the think tank and it
doesn't seem like his position is great
and wesley uh
kind of feeling his body posture as he's
digging into the position really seems
to suggest that
his play is not that easy and he's
expressing a little concern turning our
attention to the game of ray robson and
levon aronian for just a moment because
uh it's not
common let's put it that way when you're
playing on the white side of a catalan
to see
black making a threat that he just made
in the game this level of threat right
yeah right exactly so you're on the
white side of a catalan and your
opponent has just played the move queen
c6 it's just about here you ask yourself
what did i do wrong
yes uh mate in one is the fearsome
threat okay but because this bishop is
is still hanging on uh c7 it doesn't
mean that after f3 you're not playing
queen f3 because you're not on time yeah
the bishop on c7 is hanging but what do
you do because black yeah you have very
nice bishops but white's consolidation
path is pretty clear you go one rook to
d1 you play a king to f2 or g2
you can even throw in a tempo like b3 if
you really need it to defend upon c4
there's not only four it's not great but
it's not the worst the worst right as
you were pointing out it does attack b6
which means that the bishop on c7 even
if it did retreat to b8 it's not fully
comfortable because suddenly b6 is
undefended except for the queen and
again that might uh lead to certain
tactics
i don't
know where the full comp is here for rey
exactly i mean the consolidated moves
are easy yeah you do go king g2 rook d1
maybe on a good day you play knight c3
and by the way you always got this d45
kind of a tactic when you really need to
throw that in there because again b6 is
hanging so we do think the number one
seed lavon erroneon is for choice uh but
again this does feel like a position
where rey has a
full compensation as we take our
break we do want to remind everybody we
do have a single result one draw already
but you can also join the conversation
uh become a part of the show by sending
us a tweet and where do they do that
join us at twitter you can hashtag the
american cup or hashtag u.s chess champs
to join the conversation here with with
us three international master closet
kabutsuki is on our twitter and not only
answering the questions but choosing the
best ones that we will put up on air as
you can see there on twitter hashtag the
american cup and with that we'll take a
small break we're gonna let the players
figure it out wesley's definitely in a
very interesting position i don't think
he thinks right now that he's worse but
fascinating struggles there we'll come
back with all of the action of round one
of the american cup 2022 in just a few
minutes
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
[Music]
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station
with a new mirror maze light shows and
the 20-story high st louis wheel it's
enough to make any parents feel like a
star
st lou is always exploring
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we are here in the first
round of the american cup 2022 we're
still in the champions bracket as
everybody still has two lives we are the
first round of classical games we
already have one result sam shanklin
former u.s champion has drawn his game
with the black pieces against lanier
dominguez they'll face each other again
tomorrow with colors reverse as will
everybody else and we have fascinating
struggles all throughout the boards but
we were particularly interested in the
game between wesley so and sam savion
and yasser
yeah that was yeah well that was the
thing
when
wesley went for the g2g g4 move
with all of the sacrifices that entailed
he seemed to be playing with elan and
now he stopped
he
the culprit seems to be this move d4
takes c5 after d4 takes c5 the
unexpected move bishop e5 was actually a
star move because it's all about this
half open g file and the weak black king
suddenly this bishop on e5 has been
playing
this fantastic defensive role after h6
g6
wesley has just stopped and nothing
happened during the break and that's not
a good sign right you play what's
basically a forcing move to move h6 what
else can black reply that's not a g6 you
could take on d3 maybe but
more or less g6 360 because you can
always do the next
move right so you play g6 the most
natural move and then you think yeah you
stop yeah it's an indication that wesley
is not exactly enjoying the moment but
you have another uh position for us
christian as irina crush uh seems to be
enjoying her moment absolutely and
perhaps wesley does see that move rook
to h5 and he's just trying to understand
the complications after that exchange
sacrifice rook takes e5 which is going
to come on the board if he decides to go
rook h5 but yes indeed this game seems
uh to be uh going one way and one way
only and that is irena crushes way
because queen takes b7 we're looking at
this position and we're wondering okay
i take your pawn at some point you have
to take the pawn back you have to
equalize the material with knight takes
c3 she decides to wait a move okay
that's fine you can still take on c3
later on because white hasn't castled
yet white hasn't finished its
development and castle queen to d6 came
on the board of course it seems like
you're starting to threaten uh
things such as rook to ba potentially
trapping the queen which is not the case
because the queen still has this extra
square on c6 but ideas with the queen on
d6 related uh to the fact that this
queen on this is protecting the square
a6 instead of that quinto a6 came queen
to e5 once again
exchange
and take a pawn
i understand you're going to suffer this
end game is terrible after bishop to f6
take on f6 look at the pawn structure
compare it compare black spawns with
white spawns you also have the isolated
pawn i have the beautiful square on d4
this is almost decisive advantage for
white but at least it's equal material
so we're going to fight
instead of that she goes queen to e5
and right now irena says okay look i
finished my development
i took your pawns
nothing is being threatened i don't have
to worry about any sort of checkmate
threats i can always just go bishop to
g3 at some point cover up absolutely
everything there's nothing coming my way
why not just simply defend the pawn on
c3
and she did
rook to c1 is on the board i'm going to
follow up with a move c4 i'm going to
exchange my weakness for your weakness
but i'm upon up
the position is completely winning for
white and it doesn't seem like black is
creating anything this is why i'm
puzzled because in the last few moves
black hasn't created anything has
allowed white to finish his development
protect the queen beautiful placement of
the queen on a6 holding on to the attack
of the pawn on a7 a very nice uh
position on a6 i defended the pawn on c3
i'm threatening the move c4 there's
absolutely no compensation i'm just
puzzled by the fact that the youngster
did not capture uh on c3 and equalize
the material what do you guys think
i'm a material man what can i tell you
that extra pond sure looks good to me
knight d7 she played knight d7 is that
also like a 45 minute clocking at seven
yes
it is indeed yes
seven minutes for yang 45 minutes for
irena crush okay so uh clock
board serial position bishops
yeah it's all it's all the time one way
yeah street i just uh checking in on the
game between anna zatanski and tatev
this is a game that developed very very
slowly it was out of the nimso indian
and it's been
essentially a strategic struggle from
the get-go here this last move
was knight e4 by white inviting the the
trade of knights if white could ever
play knight takes e4 bishop takes e4 and
establisher or bishop on d5 white would
be very happy with such an outcome uh
tatev said no way i'm not going to allow
that she dropped back with her knight
but now came to move rook c2
making
vacating the c3 square so that she can
play knight back to c3 to d5 but it's
been a very strategic kind of dog fight
throughout so we could see something
like a maybe an f5 an e4 now you could
toss in knight d5 you can always toss in
knight d5 and i was just having a
i don't know a go if you will in british
parliament what do you think about these
apples
knight on e5 is good knight on d5 is
good but
i feel that
white is just ahead in development too
much and that if i play a move like b4
i'm not sure that you can react on time
because for example i play b6 right i
don't know how well you want to keep the
structure no i'm not well
here i'll take on b4 with the pawn and
bishop will jump to e6 and i'll complete
[Music]
i'll go c5
or knight f4 if i need to and then c5
just say when you're not dropping i'm
not dropping exactly
like white
and all my
how do you say um student body to the
king side you know g5 is not scaring you
in any it is scary but at the same time
you feel the more black plays moves like
g5 that they're weakening their own
squares
where's the real counterplay right okay
i still think it's double-edged but i
take white we'll keep an eye on them
apples
and we are going to take a look at the
brackets that we have in this tournament
in the uh bracket open with champions
bracket we have uh lavonna ronin playing
against ray robson lanier dominguez has
drawn his first game against em shanklin
uh wesley saw is currently in a dogfight
against sam savion and fabiano carano we
think he is in the better side of
us a strange position against jeffrey
xiang meanwhile in the women's we expect
irena crush to convert her crushing
advantage against ray yangyan an extra
pawn and a bunch of other things right
we like the position of begintogirionova
over caterina
uh we also like the position of alice
lee oh yes we do over uh yes over uh
solaikiru and uh we are just looking at
the game between uh ana satonski and
abrahamian and they will do it of course
all again tomorrow they're just gonna be
switching the colors so that it's a fair
match one with white one with black and
in case of a draw mini match between the
players immediately off to the playoffs
ten plus five tomorrow after the after
the classical game
and any one one ties again they play
play play all the way to an armageddon
right and uh christian you actually had
a position set up katya's position
what's going on in that position let's
take you guys through uh what has
happened in this game between m silva
and tohir genova we left it off after
this move knight to d2
puzzling move knight to d2 because after
d takes c4 you just simply don't have a
very good way to recapture and you're
going to lose a pawn which happened she
took on c4 and immediately this b4 uh
came on the board the problem with b4 is
you're not actually attacking the knight
on a5 because the bishop on b2 is still
defenseless you don't have this move
rook to b1 coming because the bishop f5
is controlling that important square so
you're going to have to lose another
tempo until i have to retreat with
this knight on c6 or even on b3
potentially an interesting move would
have been rook to c8
defending reinforcing the defense of the
pawn on c4 also potentially having ideas
of c3 in the future
did not happen rook a d8 happened on the
board which is a much more natural
approach you're directly targeting the
important central pawn on d4 asking
white to uh make their decision rook to
a2 defending the bishop on b2 now
finally this uh threat is uh enforced
and bishop b takes a5 is on tap but
after knight to c6 knight to c4 bishop
to d4 came on the board and this is just
going to simplify the position uh we're
going to end up in a much better end
game for black pawn up also a better
structure after knight takes b6 bishop
takes c3 you probably have to take back
take uh on b6 you do have the bishop
error but your bishop player doesn't
have any targets this pawn on b6 well
first of all to uh allow this bishop to
come to d4 you're going to have to play
the move b5 which is going to weaken
your pawn structure as well because my
knight is going to land on a5 and then
potentially to c4
it doesn't seem like it's going uh
kashka's way you can play the move
bishop to uh c3 but then i even have
ideas of bishop to d3 and this is one of
the key uh strategical concepts of this
position you do have the bishop er but
i'm actually going to force the exchange
of one of the bishops the light square
bishops which is probably uh your best
piece in the position and i'm going to
leave you with this dark square bishop
on c3 which is kind of facing its own
palms it's a bad bishop doesn't have any
support this pawn would like to be on b2
at least then you would have a safe
square on c3 you don't have that i'm
going to invade with my rooks on the
light squares and this one should be
quite an easy
transition for black to a victory bishop
to d4 also i want to point out the fact
that white has 12 minutes on the clock
black has 33 minutes on the clock
another one very interesting game uh
between so lucky do and alice lee we did
like so lucky the alice lee's position
but it does seem like so lucky to is
getting ready to sacrifice something on
h6 she brought her knight to g4 and
knight takes h6 or bishop takes h6 has
to come on the board the problem is
after queen to d4 if you try to do that
and she did not you play the move bishop
to c3 if you try to do that
i'm going to leave that bishop on h6
the key move in the position is knight
to d3 and this is a very typical uh move
in these type of positions
closing up the diagonal closing up the
defense also the attacking potential of
the queen on b1 just immobilizes white's
position and right now you have one
piece under attack two pieces under
attack i'm probably going to take that
bishop on h6 later on this one just
seems to be a game over and she saw that
she played the move bishop to c3
and now i'm
what if i just bishop to e4 is the
engine move and i understand it probably
gives um
black some sort of tactical ideas rook
takes e4 maybe rook two a1 is that
probably not probably not root a1 you
take take on d7 that doesn't look good
but just simply queen to c5 and without
this extra knight on e4 it doesn't seem
like your attack is going places also
the bishop on c3 is no longer on this
diagonal to support the sacrifice on h6
it does seem
like uh black is in pole position pawn
up but white still has some ideas you
know i'm going to retreat and maybe try
to bring the queen
on that side it doesn't look great for
uh for white however bishop to c3 is on
the board we're waiting for black's
response we're going to see how this one
plays out and finally
this game that you guys were focusing on
between zatonski and abrahamian
definitely a strategical battle some key
squares this d5 square probably we're
going to see an exchange maybe queen to
f7 it does seem like zatonski is
building up a nice strategical edge very
intriguing games and we are approaching
the time trouble situation
uh one player who definitely has not
landed on his feet is wesley so
wesley in this key position after h6 to
g6
h7 check king h8 again
we were looking at ideas for white with
the move rook h5 yeah rook h5 was the
key move
and
three results possible although it does
appear as if black is for choice wesley
played the move rook h6
which
invites this very obvious retreat bishop
g7 cementing
the king position you're opening up the
rook now is looking eyeballing the e3
pawn
and after
bishop g7 rook h6 back to h2
we've caught up with the players but i
must say the last few moves by white
don't seem to have this beautiful
harmony no
not a huge amount of coordination right
now you start wondering as black if i
can simplify into some kind of advantage
i specifically thinking of something
like knight takes d3 okay efficiently
five and i understand that my pawn on d5
is hanging but remember i will pick up
h7 at a later point in the game oh for
sure that that pawn on h7 is is toast
yeah but you're not giving me any choice
when you
but
but what you're doing alejandro with the
moves knight d3
queen d3 bishop f5 is exactly what i do
because i always look at the most
forcing moves force first and if i can
find an advantage from those most
forcing moves i'm going to go for it but
now that you've got here after queen
takes d5 is it
is it obvious that it's
that much knight to d4 is going to
cement i do have a tempo here not only
do i have queen takes d5 but queen c7 is
actually a bit annoying
i am threatening rook d8 and well h2 is
hanging
that is the problem i mean it's sort of
like wesley never found
it
right
was it h5h6 h2 it's not looking good and
i got to admit that that is
a very nasty tempo uh
where do i put the rook uh
ew this looks just visually good for
black the kick on h8 is super safe i
have the pair of bishops barreling down
on the queen side if i have to play
something silly like this then you're
and the c5 pawn is weak
the biggest dropping bishop coming to d3
or e6 well that was why i played rook f2
right okay but now i understand what you
mean when you say bishop e6 just to kick
my queen around
again if i allow queen to take c5 uh i
mean this is all this is
sam sam is in great shape yeah great
shape yeah no question about it and that
would be really nice
let's invite our audience to join us yes
absolutely join us here in the
conversation uh send our questions
through twitter uh at hashtag the
american cup and we have a question with
us let's take a look uh owen mcdevitt is
live the most fashionable chess player
of all
time
all time is a long time that's a long
time but he's definitely up there he's
not sporting his brand today i mean he's
really
there you see a lot more sportive uh
attire i should say and i want to say
actually that's a romanian shirt
romanian traditional shirt a romanian is
transitional the man is internationally
fashionable
that's exactly right uh i'm trying to
think outside of lavonne
who who have you
seen that you go okay he's making a
splash i like the way that anish dresses
i think it's always very professional
very clean very well presented i agree i
don't think it's it has been that's
supico that's his wife
i was preparing his wardrobe
i am not making a comment on that one i
just see the end result
looks really nice okay uh but it doesn't
have the splash that just you say that
levon has right like this with his
outfits
and ray's got the blazer he's got the
blazer look but no i'm looking for
something more uh
christian
no i i like love to be honest from the
younger generation i know hence neiman
is trying to kind of uh have his own
style you know like my name is carlson
also actually during the world
championship we were seeing him sporting
uh two sets of suits with the white
pieces he was sporting the white suit
with black pieces he was sporting black
suits so that was a nice touch but
definitely i think lev is uh one one of
a kind
i don't know if all the time but at
least of recent memory yeah yeah i'm
gonna go with level one yeah
good excellent question
yeah we like it we like it very very
very very good point
let me just say that while we've kind of
ignored it a little bit we do think that
fabi
has been in the driver's seat for some
time in this game when we left it we
left it just around these parts
um
b5 a move like we really didn't pay too
much attention to but queen
d3 to e3 well
that's making a statement just a second
uh f6 the bishop dropped back king f7
i'm not liking where this is going so
queen h6 do you have to go back to g8
i don't see another move
me unless he was going to go bishop fa
queen h7 bishop g7
that's a little bit suspicious i don't
know about that okay he didn't go queen
h6 he didn't go queen f4 either he went
knight h2 looking to go knight g4 knight
h6 h5 shutting you down
queen f3
just preparing uh vacating the e3 square
for potential of knight f1 to e3
and after b4
isn't that ironic that the the
weaknesses on the queen side you're
you're trying to undouble white's pawns
i think it's a subject of
it's difficult not to do anything in
chess right you're always trying to have
a plan of course uh in many positions
where the computer says it's equal and
they defended fine playing king h8 king
g8 computer humans can't do it right
because you don't think about these
moves you try to always do something
active have a plan precisely and of
course b5 before is a break when you
think about it more logically what are
you breaking right it's the double pawns
that white already has you're breaking
his uh already weakened structure
but on the other hand you did get access
to the d4 square which i think is the
main thing in this position of course
you can never take on b4 where knight
takes d4 is allowed but this move rook
e6 it puts it puts a serious question on
black's position right what is your next
move is the first one and the second is
can you hold everything together uh do i
have a threat first of all as white i'm
not
i'm not sure
but you're just asking what's your next
move right what's your next move and
[Music]
okay well you've played b5 and b4 with
purpose is the idea that
this is what you want to avoid i suppose
because
now the knight is going to go away from
the d4 square right but i have that so
if you should be four is that how is
that position
hello excuse me
that's an oopsy daisy no but i was
thinking instead instead of queen takes
c3 maybe white does have a thread and
the threat is simple but difficult to
meet is bishop
h4 okay i like it bishop h4 setting up
for
rook takes e7
followed by queen takes f6 and that
picks up everything
a lot of material goes
the byway after that so
bishop h4
g5 bishop g5 okay one second
this is probably not it but let's go
instead bishop h4 looks tremendous and
probably is winning is it though i mean
we could still continue or but go ahead
sorry christian please i saw this move
bishop to d6
now yes no no with the bishop g3
i was like
the engine said
i did not check it with the engine so i
don't know whether it's accurate or not
but bishop to d6
but f6 is hanging sir no no bishop to d6
for white after b takes c3 oh b takes c3
bishop to d6 for white of course yes
oops that was nice it looks funny and
probably doesn't work i mean i think you
can just simply take with the pawn
all right forget about it yes just a
second we've got a chance to
a human versus machine
[Laughter]
very interesting idea that you've come
up with uh christine by the way let's
see what he played he played the movie i
think he took the pawn b takes c3 is on
the board he takes c3 he's on the board
okay but will we see christians bishop
d6 no no no forget about it
[Laughter]
christian
it's branded stop rubbing it in hold on
it's a nice looking move it's a
nice-looking movie and the whole point
was that if you take
queen takes
you just didn't have a follow-up though
right that's the problem yeah
just just get out of uh harm's way here
but yeah all right bishop h4 i think is
the real point right right
not
sorry not um but bishop h4 i i don't see
another movie i think you have to take
on e6
g5 queen g queen h5 stop yeah yeah you
can even think
you're you're in a horrible pin and
terrible things are happening to you so
it's more you know
i think i have to take okay and i take
you take
and the question is how do we evaluate
this now the queen is definitely
superior to the rooks right the rooks it
doesn't matter they have open files the
queen has so many targets
it's just so many targets the king on e6
is very exposed but what do i do with
this tempe do i do i take on c3
okay
well first of all i would say yes right
that's like the first because
it's sort of like that knight on on d7
it just has nowhere to go
and you're almost forcing the move king
to d7 but now we can hit all kinds of
pawns we can go back three we go queen
b3
nasty hits against the pawn on d5
it's one of those positions that the
engine might say it's not so bad but
for human players the practical chance
was for white or through the roof i
think i think it's pretty bad and i i i
thought it was not so bad for black
initially because i thought okay my
knight on h2 is really bad i have to put
it on f3 one day and it's controlled
right but the moment i saw that actually
the net goes to e3 exactly the knight
goes to e3 you go knight f1 e3 either
before or after you defend the pawn on
d4 right and then you're hitting a lot
of things and i think i think that's
where white is really better and the
other point about that when we put the
knight on e3 for white we're really
killing the rook on e8 as well you
mentioned that you know with your two
rooks there are open files and you could
potentially get some counter play but a
knight on e3 is just really going to put
the kibosh on things now having said all
that uh
did fabi just play the move bishop h4 or
not yes i think there is a bishop on h4
i think that absolutely forces the move
king takes e queen takes c6 i don't see
another way to defend
let's see what jeffrey plays what is the
time situation by the way 24 minutes for
fabi 15 minutes for jeffrey
22 minutes sorry for 5 15 for jeffrey
that is not a lot of time because
remember there is no second time control
you're going to be surviving for the
rest of the game with your increment and
the remaining time that's it even though
we are saying it's classical chess 90
plus 30 is a very quick it has to be
queen
e6 right there's no other move i mean
rook takes e7 is a killer threat i mean
bishop f6 is a commitment maybe bishop
takes f6 it's very simple and very
strong right you play f5 queen g3 just
finishes the key five i don't want to
look at it and he there he takes c6 yeah
so it's a as we say box
and fabi
has forced this imbalance of two
of his queen against jeffrey's two rooks
and again it's very unusual to see this
king landed on the e6 square
but
here's the one here's a question
christian is the engine evaluation
overwhelming or we we feel it's good for
it
it is okay oh really overwhelming quite
overwhelming i think it's close to plus
two so close to our winning position
right our instincts were very good right
now the move that the engine we're just
and this is day one we're just warming
up oh yeah don't worry the engines don't
get weaker we do
i can't wait for tomorrow boy
we're getting stronger and stronger
exactly we should take it easy and in
that position actually g4 was the right
move to continue uh gathering the
advantages
after king e6
take take exchange on e6 you don't take
on c3 i'll show you guys yes okay yes
yes yes so in this position apparently
g4 is a great move that forces basically
the knight to jump back into play i'm
trying to get the knight to e3 put some
pressure on f6 as well and if not i'm
going to take the pawn on h5 i'm going
to snack on an extra pawn so g4 seems to
be a very intriguing move now of course
the big question is why not just take on
c3 which i do think is going to come on
the board i do think fabiano is going to
take that pawn on c3 it's a very king to
d7 very natural but
right now the more i'm looking at the
position it seems like white's advantage
is decreasing with every single moment
so it's g4 g4 it's it's a christmas tree
because
after queen to d3 i can go bishop to d6
i'm starting to have my own threats i
can also maybe go f5
still white's definitely in pole
position
fabiano is building up a nice edge and
probably after king takes you six uh the
time situation is going to play a
crucial role as well it seems like fabi
is on the right way let's see what's
happening in this important matchup
between aronian and ray robson because a
lot of things have happened since we
left it off after f3 of course
black had a huge threat after queen to
c6
threatening to give a checkmate queen to
g2 or queen to h1 you have to defend
against that the only way to defend
against that is either with f3 or d5
sacrificing a pawn you don't want to do
that right now so f3 came immediately on
the board rook to d7 and this is the
type of position in which as black
you are upon down you obviously have a
lot of compensation due to the fact that
you control the long diagonal you have
the two bishops but if you don't do
something immediate white is going to be
able to stabilize the position
and just be a pawn up and right now this
was the critical moment the correct move
was to go g5 as black
try to blast open the long diagonal with
a move a g4 if you follow it up with h3
i'm going to go
continue supporting this push with h5
and right now it is white that i feel
from a practical perspective is uh needs
to find the right moves you have to go
knight to c3 which still it's quite
natural and then play the move at d5
which leads to a completely explosive
and wild position i'm going to open up
uh the sixth rank for my queen
potentially go queen to g6 at one point
the king doesn't feel safe yet for white
it definitely doesn't feel safe yet and
with two bishops on the board anything
can happen instead of that
black played the move bishop to d8 did
not sense the danger of just playing
slowly slow moves exactly you have to go
for it bishop to d8 and after knight to
c3 i'm stabilizing the position i'm
bringing this knight back into play with
uh this knight to e4 landing potentially
also supporting the idea of d5 bishop to
f6 rook to d1 queen to c8 d5 take on c3
you made all this uh bishop route bishop
to d8 bishop to f6 just to sacrifice it
and exchange it for my knight on c3 it
doesn't feel right i feel right at all
it doesn't feel right and and after he
takes d5 knight takes d5 c takes d5 the
engine is uh saying that white would
have been completely dominating after
knight d5 it seems like yeah after uh
bishop takes d5 rook takes d5 white is a
pawn up of course black still can
continue the game with rook two c7 is
just upon also potentially if this c
file opens up i have this invasion
without coming to c2 there's still some
conversion problems for white but
definitely it seems like leveronian is
putting the pressure on his opponent
this is the current position we have on
the board 30 minutes for leveronian only
nine minutes for ray robson and there's
no second time controller so i'm down in
a bad position yeah we have tons of
action we're actually right let's go to
the winners section
i did not imagine christian you had a
very pressing question in that game
after the move bishop c3 what happens if
the queen simply retreats
and starula plunked down a knight on f6
sacrificing one of them pawn takes f6
didn't recapture on f6 actually went
after a very long thing the move knight
takes h6 check what is this mess we have
on the board white is currently down a
piece but well there's easier well one
move we can reject instantly is the move
uh
king f8 because that walks into queen h7
with a threat of double checkmate on f7
and g8 so therefore it really leaves
only king g7 yeah you can say box yeah
you could conserve it
but not really right then you drop f7
with a check yeah okay so king g7 now
please if you take on f7 which i think
is the most logical continuation trying
to play queen g6
you run into f5 i think which is why i
thought we were going to take on f6
first yeah but with exactly the same
idea as you're as you're pointing out
now
in this moment what is the situation on
the clock because alice with i want to
talk about it
oh it's that bad
eight minutes for white 25 for black in
a complex position so we're looking at
capture okay knight takes h6 king this
is the current situation we're looking
at king g7 then we're thinking we're
going to take this pawn with check now
if we take with the bishop we'll be
careful because that would leave this
guy hanging in one of these positions
where we go knight takes f7 check pardon
me it's not a check it's not a
checkpoint i'm i'm planning queen g6
check so i move to stop so we're
expecting knight takes
i still take on f7
i mean
takes f7 but it's killing it is it it's
completely killing i mean queen g6 you
cannot defend against that you can go
knight to d3 but then i just take it and
then continue attacking
yeah he takes f6 he's on the board
so maybe she's your student
maybe she should take with the bishop
i mean following all of those those hard
trainings or if the training is paying
off oh it always does
what is the objective of evaluation so i
think i think with the bishop right okay
so we're looking at after e takes f6
yeah i think you have to take with the
bishop on f6
okay
so that on
knight takes f7 and by the way taking
with the bishop is not an easy move to
make no no not at all practically of
course so then knight takes f7 and i
have the move knight at f8
yeah wow something about about ben
larson yeah
yeah yeah yeah well i mean the
alternatives have looked atrocious so uh
kudos so we're going to come up coming
up with this one white has a pawn for a
piece
but my goodness
hanging so we'll drop back with the
knight okay i think 95 is a great move
right yeah ah
it attacks c6 it's threatening h6 and
the threat of bishop takes b4 versus
takes b4 and
gosh this looks like a pinball were you
right
you get a score for that a score for
that and a score for that
um
wow
difficult to survive this
very game of the round i mean if this
attack works
wow out of nowhere kind of seriously
because i thought alice had covered all
the key
and the computer was very adamant when
christian was looking at it to take on
e4 first not allowing the sacrifices the
computer must have seen it in advance it
said you have to take on e4 before
retreating this queen to e7 a7 sorry
from honest to ejectively completely
winning position for black to a
practically losing position in one move
so
the whole bishop takes bishop takes
eliminate the knight yeah
and then after for example a recapture
then you just drop back with the queen
and you say look i'm a pawn up
everything's fine and i've just
eliminated this crucial
attacker that did not happen she
retreated her queen at once and this
came the spectacular night sacrifice
and we don't play king f8 of course i
apologize we we do play king g7
and we're
at this moment with alice lee and she's
taking 20 minutes take it with the
bishop talk with the bishop on f6 as we
as we thought was necessary 24 minutes
for alice lee
eight minutes for stavroula but it does
feel like these are the type of
positions that she enjoys
she attacks she's gonna take on f7 it's
on the board queen to g6 is coming you
have to defend with knight f8 and to be
honest after knight to e5 the engine is
saying that black can still survive it's
still a complicated position but
from a practical perspective it's just
feels like white is breaking through and
i'm curious how how does the engine
survive this position
because
i feel white is regaining material and
that at that moment
i mean it's just way too weak yeah queen
to e7 so we're going to
line with the knight on e5 and now queen
to e7 and on h6 you just one i'm not
sure if it's the only move i'm thinking
queen to c5 definitely looks much more
natural but queen to c5 actually loses
in instantaneously to rook to e3 so to
understand these nuances is impossible
as black
now you might ask why queen e7 survives
against rook to e3 apparently because
i'm gonna take on e5 yes good luck
finding this type of moves just giving
up the dark square bishop and allowing
uh black to
create
a deadly attack but it seems like king
to f7 king to e8 is going to come on the
board try to run for
my life on that side allowing this pawn
to move down the board no no this is not
practical chess after knight takes f7
black is in a very perilous uh situation
knight to f8 i mean if you take what
other move are you going to make
if not knight fa to defend against queen
to g6 you can take on f7 but after queen
to h7 it's very easy to see that you're
just going to get checkmated you have
the e60s
yeah once e6 drops everything is kind of
collapsing completely over so knight to
f8 will probably come on the board and
again knight to e5 is
a very simple move to make right because
it's the only one you come to that
decision very easily right your knight
is under attack
you have to defend it somehow and you
have to create threats to continue with
your initiative knight to e5 does both
of those tasks
knight planted beautifully in the center
of the board controls everything this
one is a one-way street and it seems
like so lucky dude is going to take it
all the way to the bank right arena
crush by the way as dominating irena
crush is
killing yeah extra killing
look at the knight
no i mean yeah and she did exactly what
we said she's going to do she just
played this move c4 uh pawn up
absolutely no compensation for it
pawn up and the compensation and the
count for a wide bishop takes c4 and we
have this position as i was mentioning
this bishop coming to g3 simply defends
everything you don't have any attack as
black and uh right now she's just
putting the finishing touches e4 going
to expand in the center where i have the
majority queen to e7 is on the board
three minutes also a big problem for the
youngster three minutes against 25
minutes in irena yeah she's she's not
going to miss this one she's going to
take it home
speaking of the extra pawn and
compensation turning our attention again
in
and ray robson in the open section lavon
now upon up a major piece ending we've
just seen the move rook
d-8
um
your take on this type of situation
rey's obviously in in
in bad shape
uh
what's the dream ending that he could
achieve a queen ending
take all the rooks off the board and
just get a three versus two not a passer
on the d-file though uh i think that
would be quite ideal sometimes it's
difficult to create that password when
the king is so weak i think the most
important thing for rey is to keep the
queens on the board as long as there is
a possibility to give perpetual check
right you want to at least keep the
queens and i would think uh dream
scenarios to only exchange one rook one
rook one rook one pair of rooks that
gives you more access to open files okay
but don't do it on d5 because that's
going to give your opponent a pass pawn
that's right so this is where you see
the cat and mouse game both of these
players are playing rook fda playing by
by ray please take on d7 and ron is
saying no no how about you take on d5
let me protect my work on d5 i play the
move queen e4 so you can see uh how both
sides here are strategically uh posing
themselves but uh strategy
whatever i want to go to the wesley game
against sam savion because that one had
us thrilled and what has happened a lot
of moves happened since the move
quickly
after the move rook h2 uh pardon me
bishop g7 rook h2 knight g4 he did not
uh capture on on d3 and then play for
that bishop f5 stuff he played instead
knight to e5 the rook
finally found a home that's not the home
you wanted i don't think so but uh
at least it's safe all right knight e6
by the way now that really is
in the position knight takes c5 will be
game over
knight f4 knight
oh i like this movie because you have d4
okay knight takes pawn takes nothing i
like how the knight went
yeah it helicoptered all over the board
and now we're expecting sam to play
bishop f5 and isn't that just game set
and match i mean wow is there like a oh
it was knight d6 unless 96 works oh
does it work though yes because f7
forks
if bishop f5 well how does it work
knight d6
bishop takes d3 knight takes f7 check
king h7
ah you got rook h1 not right h1 rook h1
actually i think it's it's winning but
you don't have to go king h7 right
you can go king g8 what do you mean
there's a no there's a pawn on h7 oh
sorry yeah so no no you play chuck first
because you forced the bishop to age six
what yeah
what are you doing well you know
yeah right that's why i wanted to go g8
give me your queen guys i want to take
your queen i'm hitting the bishop i'm
hitting the pawn on b7 and this is
wesley you're so saying i'm scrambling
i'm scrambling i'm surviving right right
well yeah well maybe not but okay oh
he'll be very happy to see that position
but queen v5 is i'm worried that after
knight e4 you don't have to play the
move bishop f5
25 25 queen d5
that looks really nice bishop is a
threat but also the queen 82 i think is
a threat and queen takes c5 no more
knight d6 for you yeah oh that's in
that's so important knight d6 question
mark if queen takes c5 is check and we
can sign score sheets right away oops oh
queen d5 looks very compelling too right
the moment you see bishop f5 knight d6
is a possibility you start looking for
something else exactly exactly and this
move queen d5
by the way
that's lights out i mean the more you
look at what you even do here what are
you doing you're bishop f5 is coming now
it's coming and
wesley with the white pieces
that would be a big blow definitely sam
has been doing everything correctly the
transition to this moment where he has
this move queen to d5 yeah finishing
almost finishing the game from an
objective point of view he has been
doing the right things and
it just doesn't seem like white was
doing the right things he played that
move rook to h2 then rook to h3 then g3
he didn't know where uh the placement of
his pieces should be and that allowed
black to take over the initiative and
this is exactly what sam has been doing
i have to say i'm very impressed with
the way sam has been developing in the
last couple of years and
let's not forget this is a reiteration
of
the finals of the u.s chess championship
that's what i wanted to say the big
match between wesley so
and sam savion in a rapid match sam
actually started with the black pieces
was winning in that game he lost in the
end and then was not able to recover
from that
wesley saw went on to win the us chess
championships but sam has been having a
meteoric rise in the last couple of
years went from 26.50 struggling around
that rating now close to 2700 and he's
definitely putting the hurt on this top
players look at what he's doing to
wesley so with the black pieces if he
manages to win this one tomorrow with
the white pieces walk
no wesley is going to have a very hard
task ahead of himself definitely the
2021 u.s championship said that
sam savion can play with the best of
american chess and he's showing it once
again yeah he's had a series of good
events starting uh from the us champs
going to the grand swiss over in riga
and he just played an excellent
tournament here in the st louis chess
club the spring exactly right right
where he actually came up on top of a
very strong field including some of the
players that are here ray robson jeffrey
shong was there as well exactly and
let's take a look at what happens
tomorrow it's the same matchups
but we just reversed the colors
uh one classical game but tomorrow
playoffs if necessary well not if
necessary we will definitely have
playoffs i believe at least one matchup
will finish one one right and
one player will advance in the champions
bracket the other one moves to the
elimination bracket also known as the
losers bracket in esports it's very
clear if you're in the champions bracket
you get two lives if you're in the
elimination bracket every single matchup
that you play might be your last
right
exactly exactly we did see them with
queen d5 and instantly
wesley replied with knight g5 queen d5
on the board knight g5
now
many questions but
the simple one is what happens if i go
bishop f5
that is the most simple question you're
gonna try to bail out into some sort of
an end game with queen b3 aren't you
queen
well b3
maybe one or bishop c3
well there is knight f7 don't forget
there is a knight
so king d1
but how serious of a threat is that i
understand that knight f7
on a vacuum wins but if i play something
like rook i think how do we defend this
pawn right yeah so you're just saying
how big of threatening
bishop e4 is an issue yeah
oops that queen on b3 is actually
defending quite nicely uh the king
so just a second knight g5 it just feels
like this is the moment how is the end
game yeah how is the end game
before we get into that what if i
is it too much to throw in f6
is that asking too much from life oh my
god it probably is right it probably is
asking too much from no actually funnily
enough it was the first move i
considered
and i liked it a lot except i liked
other moves too
queen a2
it's queen a2 completely ridiculous as
well i mean it just it just says look my
next move is bishop f5 and i do yes in
fact want to checkmate you on b1 i think
it's queen b1
that
that throws it off come on guys okay so
christian uh
no it seems like bishop f5 is the right
move bishop f5 yeah
bishop f5 but
well the one thing i i dislike about f6
these rooks are ridiculous yeah the
rooks are the most ridiculous
they're on a g-file that is not
going anywhere when you play f6 you give
them
purposes yeah right okay so bishop f5
okay we went queen b3
uh let's go into the end game right so
oh you want to trade yeah oh by the way
she he played the queen takes c5
immediately immediately
which might spoil the position well i
didn't like that it gave away f7
like the square f7 you're giving up a
tempo basically because of that right
yes so now king to d1 i think might be
forced right well i was about to say
wasn't queen c2 queen to c2 but queen to
c2 i'm just going to exchange bishop to
f5 and that has to be a winning endgame
agreed okay so
no came to d1 i'm preserving this killer
threat of taking on f7 and checkmating
you
how is this position can i go bishop f5
[Music]
if i um if i would have done that the
previous move right right exactly what
why why would i do it now yeah why would
you give up f7 yeah with the challenge
you have to
and now you're in a in a position well
you can go back knight to g5 and i think
that's winning knight g5 you've been
winning for white you're right g5 and
then queen b3 exactly yeah i've got rook
h no no you don't play queen c5 with
bishop f5 you've done it the other way
around not in time so but white has to
go king to d1 right okay it's fair fair
fair but now it's just
is it just time to defend
like you should be six maybe
what fashion should be six yeah just
defend the pawn
somehow i'm not asked convinced
about this variation but the k9 is still
pretty weak but now you're almost
allowing me to activate my rooks aren't
you
taking f5 yeah
[Music]
and like these rooks which were were
without purpose a moment ago
are suddenly for the first time it's
very difficult here for black noise keep
everything together and the pawn on c5
it feels like a piece i could have taken
at any point yeah why yeah queen takes
c5 who feels like it gave up a lot of
white pardon me black's advantage
and
you know against wesley you're permitted
to make
one two
light
mistakes
uh but not not this
not not not here i think that that was a
a big slip and by the way what is the
times of the players it's nine minutes
for savien and 13 minutes for wesley no
i think it's seven minutes for sam
savion
minutes before
you see it there on the box yep
and
wesley kind of feeling that he's got a
moment he went king d1 fast
yeah he he is
let's see black's defense queen to d5
he's very cool
i like the fact that it was played
quickly i don't care if it was a good
mover right as a coach you're like hey
boom hey especially when i see my
players thinking half an hour
in a 25 minute game but also it's it's a
it's sort of like okay i
this is a demonstration that hey man i i
knew you were gonna play king d1 i have
my answer prepared my answer is going to
be queen d5 it's not going to be bishop
e6 it's not going to be any of the other
stuff white only has one move here right
if you don't play
queen b3 what else do you play
and that is the trick that's why he took
on c5 first not only to take a pawn
but actually right now
with the king on d1 after queen to b3 i
have the extra option of giving it
back to g4
intermediate who finishes the game on
the spot oh
that's a nice move yeah
that is really really nice so as white
you're thinking to yourself all i really
want to do is play knight takes f7 i've
got to eliminate the defender
of the f7 pawn i'm going to play queen
b3
and in case you trade then at the end of
the day the pawn will be hanging
the queen is relying upon the defense of
the rook on g3 and that is why black
tosses in
the move bishop check
oopsy daisy now there is no rook takes
g4 because that would leave the queen
hanging and there before you have to go
king
c1 and very bad things are
have occurred
essentially
for
so what's the westlake fights move here
if you don't have them with queen v3
because that is the most natural way of
playing
my fife is coming anyway
i was wondering how bad the sacrifices
were with knight takes f7 and rook takes
g6 uh frankly at this point it's like
i'm desperate and that's proud yeah yeah
and uh i hadn't calculated them i had
not calculated them i assumed
that bishop f5 was just refuting
everything but i i didn't check but it
looked very cool because rook g7 queen
h5 we can stop you are very correct
about that yes sir and that is why what
you have to do and let's take a couple
of uh moves back
you have to start with the move queen to
f3
that's a tough one very difficult
very very difficult because also black
can just simply take on f3 and go into a
much better end game clear now
bishop e6 is probably the best move but
let's look at the most
practical move which is queen to a2 it
doesn't seem like queen f3 i go queen a2
and i'm gonna checkmate you right
exactly yeah
but the key idea behind it is that the
queen is no longer on the b1 h7 diagonal
so bishop 5 doesn't come with tempo now
i can take on f7
queen takes f7 blue to g6 wow
what
wow and white is fine
white is fine white is actually slightly
better what slightly better no
i don't know how works if he finds queen
f3 with this idea i i i you're saying
that after this
stunning
sacrifice white is slightly slightly
better better yes yes i think there's
ways to force some sort of chance it's
not fair no no no no this is this is
really not this is not how chess works
this is really cold no no so queen f3
the very attractive answer duck of queen
82 is refuted by knight
christian you party pooper
why don't we even invite him
i just don't get it off the christmas
list that's it
i want to update before we get too much
into this the game of star will it
because a lot has happened since we last
uh checked out that game
uh
the next one
k98 thoughts of things happen we left it
on knight takes f7
sorry i just hit the
go back button a little bit too quickly
there night nine two three we didn't see
this coming in but it's more like clever
moves bishop takes and while the queen
is blocked right i'm coming to g6 but i
love this clearance sacrifice bishop
takes c4 i will not be stopped i will
not be stopping when it comes to h7 king
8 i assume you take on e6 now i don't
see why you would do it in the next move
exactly and it's all how do you say
a la tempo right i mean it looks really
it looks pretty finito and let's let's
continue
i think i just take on c6
there might be another move but
by the way this is the three pawns
versus peas
where the three pawns are really good
this is the pawns of making their way up
the board already and black's king is
yeah the pawn on h5 is actually
promoting
right
queen g8 is a huge threat bishop this is
a threat
don't have a maiden made into threat
yeah you don't have time to take on c3
because of that
just to show everybody bishop takes c3
no time as alejandro was saying
oops that's a pattern
worth hard wiring
so what do you do
this one i give it up yeah i think i
think this is this looks busted for
black but it was a nice try knight dc
that was a nice try knight d3 but it
seems to not be quite enough she has
taken on c6 i can see that on the board
and
this looks finito
well i mean black's not even enough
material anymore yeah the training is
paid out there of course
wow uh
alice lee will be regretting that she
didn't uh capture on before when she had
a chance yeah and what about the fabiano
versus jeffrey game christian completely
changed switched
after king to e6 queen to c3 that was
the practical decision right right right
take the pawn don't play g4 of course g4
is winning according to the engine don't
play it just take the pawn on c3 right
which he did came to d7 and now he lost
the move he played the move knight to f1
he was supposed to continue attacking
black's targets that is queen to d3
focus on the light squares focus on
black's weaknesses try to put blacks
force black's pieces into passive
squares that is rook to g8 potentially
or
play the move f5 which would create a
lot of weaknesses that my knight can
take advantage of knight to f3 jumping
to e5 and so on instead of that he
played the move knight to f1 very
natural move of course you want to go to
e3 you want to put some pressure on d5
this is the focus of white's play and it
makes a lot of sense right the problem
is that this move rook to b8 comes on
the board and now is black who is
starting to find the counter chances
because after knight to e3 this is just
simply losing rook to b1 king to h2 g5
this might have been the move that he
missed the idea that after bishop to g3
i'm just going to continue with h4
you're going to lose bishop
bishop is completely trapped rook to b8
my goodness an incredible resource found
by jeffrey and after g4 which he played
a bit too late fabiano that is take take
rook to b1 king to g2 getting off this
pin i want to play knight to e3 but i'm
just in time to create my own initiative
with the move rook to d1
attacking this pawn on d4 just in time
queen to h3 is on the board rook takes
d4 bishop takes f6
bishop takes f6 g5 but right now after
rook to e6 you're going to take here i'm
going to go rook to f4
it's black who's playing for a win right
now wow
everything has changed of course it
seems like that after knight to e3
probably white still have uh more than
enough to maintain equality right yeah
queen and the knight have a very nice
cooperation and it seems like the king
is a bit too exposed
but
jeffrey escaped
with black pieces most likely the game
is not over no but most likely even from
a practical perspective it seems like
the worst is behind him
and this one is uh probably going to end
up oh my goodness he played queen a2
oh queen f3 was found queen 282 is on
the board knight takes f7
equalizes the game that's such a
seductive move queen
how do you not play guys i hate to
interrupt this but we have to switch the
levon game because he is about to win oh
boy and we we really should put it on
the board while he's still there this is
a winning end game as you can see
there's a pawn on c7 right that
completely kills paralyzes the rook
paralyzes the rook every pawn end game
is obviously lost right if you pick up
my pawn i'll go f4 f5 f6 shatter your
structure and win the opponent game
right so as that's what he's going for
as black's king goes towards the pawn
then what alejandro was saying was that
f4 f5 f6 while you're
picking up the pawn on c7 he's playing
f4 f5 f6 and that was why uh ray in this
position after c7 did not go
came to d7 he played king f
king f6 but lavon said okay
i'll hit you with the check
and this has to be lost everything that
i've been taught about chess yeah
absolutely absolutely
i think you can go four but every move
should win i i was thinking that i would
not have played the check personally
myself i would have played f
g4 f4 g6
f4g6 then i'll move my king back to you
you're still winning but
why why allow g6 i i want to keep my
king on h5 so that you can go king takes
h6 against g6 uh oh we've got christian
over here with his jaw i can't on the
phone
i cannot
this is the position on the board right
now
check out this line
d3 right threatening
queen to b3 it's clear queen takes d3
bishop to f5 give me it looks like i'm
winning right absolutely it looks slower
rook takes g7 but queen to h5 check i'm
going to pick up the queen this is over
resign king to c1 bishop c3
rook to c7 with the threat of bishop
bishop c3 is a threat no no a8 you're a
queen down queen down it's equal
to e7 is the only move bishop to c3 king
takes h7
what
what king to h6 bishop to g7 and now
this is just a perpetual get out of here
you're on your computer
well i don't know if it's only the
computer because wesley is going
straight into this line rook takes jesus
he's on the bar key wesley no probably
d3 does look winning right hey i'm gonna
go queen h5 check on rook g7 he sees
something he sees something two minutes
two minutes for sam two minutes versus
eight in such a complex position but
these three's so tempting of course
two three how can you not play d3 here i
understand that
moment you touch that pawn bishop c3 is
an alternative right
it might be the only move to maintain
equality for black because that's what
rook g7 is i mean i don't use that when
he's big yeah it's a big threat but it's
like yeah you played the move d3 that's
the third rail you know something
could go wrong with bishop c3 but the
idea that you're a queen up and you and
you have to accept a perpet
that is just
brutal
and look and wesley is looking at his
opponent and he sees
he doesn't like it he doesn't like it
look at his face he did not like this
move
he might think that he's losing yeah i'm
thinking
yeah i mean stumble into the equal line
i mean christians show me that it's
equal and i still don't believe it queen
takes d3 bishop f5
takes seven queen h5 check
picks up your queen full free for free
and it's a draw that's remarkable by the
way lavon aronian has played that line
with f5 and he's easily winning continue
with the line you've got it in front of
you alejandro was asking a very
important question and that is
in this position why not bishop to c3
right but this one is losing
because of queen to c5
and then i'm just simply going to
sacrifice my queen i'm going to be a
pizza no because if you go to rook g8
i'm going to take and then you cannot
follow up but hold on rook h1 is made
why not because i think on g8 i know i
go rook g7 check yes king h6 oh now you
have queen back there
no
no way there's no way
yes yes that's wesley has several
cameras
i want to see this yeah yeah yeah that
is amazing wesley has seven minutes to
find this d3
queen he's forced to think
oh my goodness
completely losing obviously yeah
right three he can resign
oh what a miss
what a miss indeed well what a tough
move to find though
i mean we still don't believe it and you
know we've got the computer here telling
us yes it's true and we're going no it
can't be queen d3 bishop f5 rook g7 i
thought he might stumble into this line
just right because everything else is
just thinking he's completely losing and
just play the moves right and this is
where we are now expecting sam savion to
play the move d3 d2 and is on the board
winning the game with the black pieces
resignation wow what a game
what a game here by both sides so many
resources this is a classical guy
sometimes
you just tip your hat and say well done
guys
wow okay so why do we think it's so bad
for wesley
king takes d2 what's the crunchyroo
probably be sure about five just bishop
f5 yeah queen and my king is on now
you're just getting mated exactly my
king's on the open highway two moves
from checkmating me and i'm checkmating
you first exactly i see that you've got
the game of anna satonski over on your
side but i i think we're going to see
your resignations yeah exactly
let's keep here that's the interesting
one no question i'm just going around
making sure that there's nothing
untoward yeah nobody's finishing just
yet doesn't seem like it
and if you go
king to f2
yes
i can just probably take on
e3 and simplify everything and then
maybe you could even under promote with
chess
just to
bring the rules that's a good move
actually yeah
you're a mean man yeah
i like that move
it is a bit mean it is cruel let's see
what he plays
king f2 yes
so under promotion is definitely an
interesting move you go there make a
knight
he played something right assume that's
a knight no he that's a queen that's
no
he resigned
yeah yeah yeah he resigned he made a
queen and and that was that's the game
wow
wow what a result what a spectacular
game but what are we sold here for sam7
taking down the us champion with the
black pieces he just needs a draw
tomorrow to knock him down to the
elimination bracket
sam savion thrilling game gambled and
here we have the moment bishop e3 who
could have taken on these three crazy
lines guys we have a ton of chess to
look at elrodian has won against ray
robinson ray has resigned that game so
we have two winners so far today uh
levon aronian haven't defeated ray
robson samsung with the black pieces
against wesley saw jeffrey shang still
playing against familia carrana let's
take a look quickly at uh the other
section as the women's games are pretty
much heating up on all of them wow no
results in no results in any of the
games there yet
winning quickly she still looks like
she's got this game so completely won
um
this game catering
as we can have the boards maybe yeah
katya is a pawn down struggling mightily
i would say black should win that game
maybe we should put this sorry people
can look at
uh them the game that yasser has on his
board which is katjaz
nem sova
versus begum
and
katja's but basically upon down the
bishops of opposite color gives white
some hope but in this particular
position it just feels like
man black has just got everything uh
going for her so i really feel but
it's not that clear right no i mean it's
the bishops of opposite color uh gives
whites definitely not clear no no no but
look at the time look at the time
yesterday oh the time 40 seconds for
nemtsova
10 minutes eight minutes for uh
tahir jhanova well that's that's a big
time of that very huge that's huge yeah
and how about the alice lee game the
sacri the sacrificial game that was
keeping us on the edge of our seats well
zero zero almost what what
alice has fought her way somehow
how did she do that when we left it we
thought it was all over including the
shouting i still think white is
definitely going to press this position
and probably win with the four pawns she
has a lot of pawns i'm shocked this is
zero zero he does also yeah i i mean how
do you how do you trade queens how do
you trade queens
wait a second did she trade quiz
voluntarily
yes the queen's uh
wow okay so we but it's four pounds
you're gonna have a field day uh uh
training with uh rule after this one and
talking this queen trade off
because f7 is on the board now i
understand
actually yes if the pawn was on h5 now
it's winning
no it's not winning right is it it's
it's much better it's going to be a prac
practically it feels like you're very
close to completion
uh the thing is that rook to d1 and then
rook to d5 was the critical uh way in
which she could have equalized position
and the ruler was only 15 seconds on the
clock but it doesn't matter so much in
these positions because well you don't
have that much to blunder rook g4 is a
bizarre move in mind why why do you need
rook g4 allowing knight g6 i don't know
what
that doesn't look good
rook to g4 okay probably she's gonna
drop back to c3 that's that's her idea i
understand that
but
this will be a long game i think white's
first choice right but this will take a
while definitely
exactly and what's happening in
the zatansky ooh that rook on b6 looks
how did the rook get there trapped
somehow but also how did it get there
not sure that one either
this has to be winning for white somehow
queen b8 or something yeah but i i was i
was looking at queen b8 oh then you want
to go queen f4 no queen b bishop b5 just
give me the line
maybe there is no line here that was
without i don't know i maybe you have to
start with like h
four or something just okay
h4 makes a lot of sense maybe it's not
that easy
but it doesn't yeah it's it's not
intuitive it's not intuitive
right
okay let's go back to the open section
for just a quick second we've already
gotten two wins
out of the four games played one game
was a draw but the game
that really had our attention for the
longest time was fabi versus
jeffrey zhang jeffrey was in trouble but
has fought his way back
with the two rooks against the queen and
jeffrey looks good i can't imagine that
there's any problems here for black but
the king is so weak
i don't think that you're fighting for
an advantage either
but what how are we going to deal with
rookie four let's start with
with very concrete moves
well for that moment and then i'm i'm
going to start to
do what get my
my king out of uh pins so let's start
with rookie four all right i'll go queen
d1
it's white to move right
oh i'm sorry yeah 97 was just like
there was a reason why the computer
wasn't letting me playing the move that
i wanted i was like what's wrong with my
mouse uh queen d4 check king c8 okay
king c8 on the board and
if i'm black i'm really want i'm
embracing a trade of the night yeah i
really want to trade the knights off the
board and play the rook against the
queens yeah i think that white
because of the weakness of the king
really doesn't want that to happen okay
i think you could consider queen a7
right it's
not such a bad move i'm not going to get
my queen trapped
hopefully not queen a7 not a bad move
says
alejandro and here i was hoping the
knight d5 i still have
so that was the whole the whole
the idea that the knight does not come
with uh to f5 at the tempo and the fact
that you're on a7 means that you're
hitting
c7
well well one thing about the move queen
a7 and i like it a lot is you're just
being belligerent
you got to be annoying sometimes you're
going to just stop your opponent from
doing what
you're trying to do i do that i do get
that pretty often
played no i'm not talking about dates
we're talking chess
queen a7 played on it yeah i think the
queen is just too annoying for jeffrey
to have a realistic winning chance here
right right mcqueen is always going to
be harassing the a6 pawn some perpetual
but
obviously with the two rooks being such
potent positions the
not playing for a win either no
okay we definitely keep an eye on this
game as we go back to our ladies section
and over to christian as arena crush
appears to be putting the finishing
touches
not so much not so much
i mean well right now she does have a
dominant position but she did miss
knight takes d7 rook takes d7 this
position is starting to be very close to
some sort of opposite color bishop
position in which potentially black
could claim that his uh she's closer to
a draw i had this great
she did and she exchanged it with knight
to d7 which was a tremendous mistake
rook to b7 bishop to c6 would have been
quite okay for black actually the engine
only gives white a slight edge after
rook to b4 of course i go back maybe i
just stay like this and i'm waiting i'm
waiting to see what you're going to do
next and at the same time i'm going to
put some pressure on the pawn on a4
potentially block it with a move a4 and
then try to exchange the queen's queen
c4 if you don't do something fast
i'm going to be able to uh simplify the
position and potentially make a drop
but
we have four well we have a result
anastasia
it was h4 rookie 6 g3 take a look at it
so sorry to interrupt your uh train of
thought there christian but we did see
this move queen c7 and it's checked it's
a double attack goodness i'm sorry
she's was it a time trouble uh induced
error one minute on the clock
yeah king
double question mark king g7 and she
walked into
check
resign or something
uh
continue your train of thought there
with irina's uh position or
if you if you like christian
well again i was just looking at this
position once again she did play the
move queen to a3
after bishop to c6 the computer is only
giving white a slight edge of course
still pawn up still black doesn't have a
good way to try to create any sort of
attack against white's king is very safe
on h2 but
it's not as easy to break through right
so bishop to c6 might come on the board
and it seems like the youngster is
fighting for her life right now crazy
remarkable this is in a deep deposition
yes and let's see what happens but we do
have a very special guest right now with
us in the studio a man that played a
tremendous game today that is leveronian
lev welcome to the studio welcome st
louis welcome back to st louis tell us a
little bit about the format of the event
how do you approach it and how do you
feel about the format of this event
um
i think
when you play chess for
30 years
you don't care about the format
you're just happy to be in front of the
board
and to have a chance to compete with
some of the best players in the world so
it's
i mean i'm happy with every format but
of course the format is very exciting
because
uh normally uh one mistake and you're
gone in a
knockout tournament here you have a
chance to you know
be kind of a zombie and come back
come back to life
tell us a little bit about this
particular matchup against ray robson i
was doing some research and i couldn't
find any games between you
is this a completely new opponent for
you
yes we have never played which is quite
surprising because
ray is an established
player
you know i have
high regard for him as one of the most
talented players
from america
but surprisingly yeah we've never played
and yeah today was our first game and it
worked well for me quite an intense game
let's uh go through that one take us
through the opening phase
uh actually we got to this point uh
lavonne a very interesting bernoulli we
won't ask you about your preparation but
after the move a2 a3 uh take it from
here how did you like your position and
uh what was your feeling i can't really
say i like my position but uh this is uh
not the type of position that ray has
played before i he he kind of surprised
me with first movie six
and that he went for this line
and i was thinking okay position is
quite balanced and uh yeah at this
moment this was definitely a critical
moment in the game after knight b3
uh because so far i think all rays move
make perfect sense sure and here i think
he went for this inaccurate b6 i thought
that uh after knight e5
knight edgar five yeah yep
the the problem was that
i was kind of hoping that knight d4
would work but it doesn't at all because
bishop takes a4 queen a4 knight d3
rookie 3 and knight f2
is crashing
nice because king f2 queen f6 knight f3
queen b2 and
yeah this is some yum yum time
very nice variation for sure and so i
thought what am i going to do because
from distance i thought maybe i have
this knight c5 after knight e5 uh yeah
i think
95 knight bc5
bishop c6 uh knight b7 i thought maybe
this will work
but it also doesn't work because bishop
takes g2 king g2
and queen d7 is extremely powerful here
because
after knight
bc5 queen c6
f3
knight g4
is very painful
otherwise white is doing fine but this
knight g4 is extremely painful
wow
so i probably had to opt for something
like f4 here after knight bc5 bishop c6
and
f4
and hope for
equality like something like f4 here
yeah i see yeah i really need to push
this knight away because he's
feeling
too good this night there exactly so you
were very happy about this opportunity
with the move b6 to play the move bishop
takes c6 yeah because after this at
least i'm never worse i just want to
point out the fact that actually this
game has been seen before in five games
and knight to e5 does give black the
advantage
with the variation that you showed
wow
were you aware of that even no no
where you are
you study you prepare but not to that
depth that you could guess yeah
i was surprised guys
give me a break okay look i'm completely
with you
and quickly after d4 f3
everything went very smoothly it felt uh
lavone after yeah well i was thinking
that the position should be slightly
better for me but uh it's nothing really
special and here of course it looks very
good you know he had this funny option
i'll just quickly show you with the
bishop on c7
he has this rook fd8
uh right now yeah yeah i have to play
rkd1 otherwise knight c3 rook d4 and he
gets tremendous compensation agreed uh
bishop e5
yeah
but i have to play knight b6 which is
giving me the advantage otherwise
the point is that rook before knight d4
bishop before knight d5 i've got
marvelous that is yes bishop e5 very
very shocking
because of queen f3 yeah yeah this rook
d2 move after these
exactly yeah the funniest part of the
engine wants to play bishop v8 wait for
you to play one of the knights of c3 and
then go bishop e5 ah yeah yeah no i saw
this idea yeah fantastic so essentially
because we've got so much going on lavon
uh we were going to go back uh the
ending became winning just about what
point in your opinion when did you say
okay this is 90 it's such a difficult
position to play with little time i
thought this is practically losing for
black i see so at this point it's and
then you know this f4 trick is always
working in this position so
this is i'm glad i knew yeah that i have
this king d7 f4 and take six f5 okay
exactly yeah exactly so white is winning
because of that f4 f5 f6 thrust exactly
our our resident chess coach coach of
the year
has pointed it out it must be some
classical knowledge lavon
congratulations great start and good
luck in your
game tomorrow thank you absolutely a
pleasure to see levon playing that way
and we have our first result there game
one goes to lebanon that means that ray
robson is in a must-win situation if he
wants to keep in the champions bracket
right uh otherwise he will go down to
the elimination bracket and i have a
draw is happening in the game between
familia karana and jeffrey shanghai it
looks like he's
he's claiming a repetition a threefold
repetition i think jeffrey is checking
he usually doesn't mess this ones up
fabiano doesn't but uh even if the claim
is wrong i don't think that the game was
going anywhere exactly and
it looks like uh
jeffrey
accepted that indeed that was the case
that a three time repetition so for the
open section all the results are in
and we are still waiting on most of the
women's sections games
remember
defeated
defeated
that's what happened and we are winning
on the rest of the results are going to
crush still with a commanding position
against riyang yang the other two games
up in the air but uh as we see that rook
finally coming into the seventh rank but
we do have with us in the studio a
brilliant winner
already a candidate for game of the
tournament we have sam savion who
defeated wesley so with the black pieces
thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with the man of the hour who defeated
wesley so with the black pieces sam
savion first of all i want to take your
pulse how do you feel right now after
such a tremendous rollercoaster victory
um i feel great honestly it was a crazy
game uh he came at me at the with in the
opening with this crazy quincy to h4
idea but i'm really happy with how i
defended after with h5 which is kind of
counter-intuitive
giving him this g4 hook but if i don't
do that he's going to play g4 g5 and
probably just make me
did you analyze these positions at home
or was it a complete surprise for me oh
no he's never played this i definitely
never looked at this
so let's go through the game uh did you
feel in danger
at any point yeah
this is the moment where
for us
uh as you just said it's so well
yourself sam after the move h4
h5 is not the type of move uh that
you're looking to play it is
counter-intuitive but the alternative
allowing g4 g5
is you just get rolled off not pleasant
yes so whether you liked it or not after
h5 castles a7 a6 he came at you guns
blazing with the move g4 yeah i mean i
was really happy when he started
thinking after a6 because
i mean at least he's out of book
or not in his prep yeah
yeah exactly so at what point did you
say started thinking right uh here i
already felt like i can definitely win
this game because
either i'm winning an exchange
well it's not either i'm or or what
happened in the game basically he has to
play these weird moves like h6 through
page two and then his attack we were
our main move was crazily enough to move
rook h5 right here i actually expected
rook h5 bishop g4 yeah and
do you stack or go h7 first that was the
correct way bishop to g4 was a very
important h7 first
first okay
and then sack and then maybe knight f4
yeah we
is that we were looking at knight f4
something bishop e1 or something like
that
yeah forcing knight takes d3 that's
right yeah so that basically i can play
like knight take but bishop is really
nice to me because now if i take and go
bishop f5 f6 you have bishop g3 at the
end yes that was the internet that's
deep id yeah that was the intention uh
just for everybody what we were what uh
sam was saying that uh bishop queen d4
yes bishop f5 queen d4 f6 and bishop g3
is how white gets compensation for his
exchange so we were kind of expecting
rook h5 and we thought
that what he did
kind of helped you kind of play yeah i
was very happy to see this exactly
although he has an interesting idea with
rook h2 i think after knight takes d3
after rook h2 if i take on d3 and play
bishop f5 which i initially wanted to
play which seems very um straightforward
shall we say yeah
for example if queen takes d5 yep a
queen c7 yeah
rook t8 with tempo it just looks like a
great position correct that was uh what
alejandro was
i kind of got worried about the queen
sack with queen takes f5
after bishop f5 whoa i don't think we
looked at this one alejandro queen
not here uh movago
yes no we didn't see that at all
what
sorry to interrupt you there but irina
crush has finally converted her winning
position against riyan yan he goes up a
match point there
but let's go this craziness
two bishops just were eliminated off the
board rook g8 made what's insane is
let's say i go um
knight g6
yes he can consider taking this knight
and once again anything with bishop c3
is right it's scary very scary yeah but
this is why i didn't find something
right right yeah knight f4 knight d5 oh
like yeah no
uh i wasn't interested in this
medina uh would be very happy with you
uh in this case
which is why you went knight jeep yeah
just put the net on the in the center
and then 96 comes yeah and here you were
you you were really cruising and you
found a nice trick with 94 two points if
a bishop f5 he wants to play
knight d6 knight d6 yeah or knight g5
yeah and yes yeah and that was why we
thought
one question did you take a look at the
engine
no but i i i
we'll get there
and we'll get very quickly to this
incredible moment right
if you go back a few moves there's a
nice trap he had uh
here when i took on c5
if i go bishop f5 first
yes
queen queen b3 is his idea
okay
and now queen takes c5 suddenly he has
rook c3
and then
yeah whoops that turns the tables
wow
wow
oops
yeah very nice that's right i had to
take on c5
okay we unfortunately did lots of stuff
so we'll just wrap it up very well did
you see here i did see so when i
initially played queen a2 i thought d3
wins yes and then when this position
happened i was i was shocked
i saw rook c7
oh yeah yeah yes he saw it
that's incredible i start rookie c7 i
finally found rookie seven holds
but it's just amazing how the table is
turning after queen takes d3 here
incredible
yeah
queen takes d3 bishop and you saw
because i was spending a lot of time i
was sure d3 wins it was just rechecking
and then suddenly
bishop city queen c5 wins but what if he
goes roxy 7 first
it's just a shocking brilliant move
wow sam a huge victory for you
congratulations
and good luck tomorrow thank you well
done what can you say that's just
amazing i mean it's just an incredible
game you're a queen up
you're a queen up and it's a draw no i
mean that's incredible rookie five
i mean the fight that sam saw just shows
you the amount of talent you can find in
this tournament yeah rook c7 finding
that
to stop the rook coming and giving up
actually it's just incredible
so sam
and needs a drone just needs to draw
with the white pieces tomorrow against
wesley so i'm sure that he'll play as
solidly as possible but still a lot to
play for in that match wesley will do
his best with the black pieces to come
back in this match it's gonna be a tough
one um
so all of the open section
has finished yes uh we have two decisive
results two draws and two draws
jeffrey's showing the draw against
fabiano caruana they'll be playing
against tomorrow and in the women's
section so far two decisive games as
irina crush did defeat uh january young
and anna satonski defeated tatev abraham
we have two games left in today's rounds
as a bad game is i believe still trying
to beat um caterina
with the extra point with the extra pawn
and alice lee is holding
it shouldn't be much of a difficulty to
hold this end game where she's up a
piece but facing the three pawns it's
white that surely is better in this
position but
i mean i don't expect this to be
anything other than a draw and we have
in studio anna sustansky with christian
thank you yasser yes we are indeed with
a very happy victory of today's round
anna congratulations thank you you know
tatif quite well you've played her so
many times did you ever play her in a
match situation
no never i think it's it's very new
format and how did you approach this
match
okay i prepared so this was something
new i saw that she played in blitz this
variation bishop d2 and i just decided
to
to do something about it yeah and it's
she surprised me with move c5 after
bishop d2 c5
you both were kind of uh taking your
time trying to understand the position
did you see this before did you analyze
no
i forgot or i didn't see
take us through the game and don't you
feel like you're taking over
uh probably
right when i played just six
it's six
yes yes okay it's like
and
here e5
so here we're thinking queen c2 but then
g6 like in the game and i need to space
for my rook of course of course queen c2
is more natural move but then after
yes here queer queen to g6 i don't have
this maneuver this i need the square c3
square for my knight
like when your knight is coming back you
anticipated the game yeah yes yes i saw
97 for sure which i was quite happy
that's why i played queen v1
and rook and that's the whole point of
your maneuver yes and c3 to c2 so your
queen cannot occupy the square
that is a very nice idea
and you get to a position
at this point how are you feeling a
little bit better yourself oh i had like
um
i thought like i have some pressure but
she was about to equalize and i don't
know why she didn't play queen d6 the
most natural move could be six and then
or like exchanging everything right
bring the rooks to the scene so maybe i
still have like slightly i don't know
like uh
in the game it's easier to play with
white that she has allowed you instead
after this after this six i already had
feeling that i have advantage
exactly
and then here it's kind of like she
mobilized her rook
on d6 it wasn't completely clear still
at this point
but king g7 kim just seven is just
terrible yeah
and now
uh
okay we had like here like two minutes
and yes
this is uh
was already blitzing like last ten moves
so it's difficult to play such position
for black when you are defending
i see
and i think it's i already had
experience playing with this time
control so i think it was
i already knew how to play how to
distribute time right so uh your your uh
feelings about the format this double
double match elimination okay i i can
tell you that from my point of view it's
a lot of pressure when you're playing
match but then i think it's like
spectators like chess fans will benefit
like really a lot and i think it's this
is great idea
and double elimination this is also good
because you will see the same players
already lost right continue playing and
i i think it's so it's a very good idea
yeah
now the fact that you have a second life
does it make it a bit more bearable that
tension in the first match
say it again the fact that you have a
second life even if you lose one mesh
then you still get the second life yes
is it more bearable detention in the
first match yes i think so i think so
and also this is not like what do you do
with this player so they will go home
yeah yes
you give them a chance and i think it's
a very good idea
good excellent anna good luck tomorrow
we're looking forward to see your game
thank you anna thank you for joining us
yeah and she will be defending with the
black pieces remember a draw will be
enough for her to remain in the
champions bracket right and that is what
she will be trying to do
tomorrow against tata
well known players to each other they've
been fighting at the us championship for
many many years actually over a decade
already
we'll see what tatif brings to the board
and we have uh only two games remaining
begging
by the way
yeah i was about to say completely
winning completely winning i don't
really know how this happened but i mean
katya is the lost uh
bishop comes to e4 pawn goes to g4 and
she's resigning and she's resigning wow
so three decisive games for the ladies
to start
this american cup 2022 right and we
expect it to stay that way as alice lee
should draw against sterile telekite at
any moment but while they're finishing
up that game yeah this looks very dead
uh we have with us fabiano caruana who
drew his game against jeffrey chung
certainly had most of the pressure
throughout the game but not able to
convert he's with christian thank you
alejandro yes we are indeed with fabiano
caruana fabi first of all tell us how do
you feel about the format of this event
it's completely new and it seems very
exciting yeah it's an interesting format
but the the really new thing i think for
the players is the time control it's not
entirely new like we've played with with
this time control and i haven't played
with it for a decade or so
i mean it's um
it's very unforgiving because you you
never get more time
and at some point like if you're under
time pressure it's for the rest of the
game
so um yeah the format is interesting and
the time control is also quite exciting
did you do any specific preparation uh
for this time control did you play any
training games
no no i don't think you can
find someone willing to sit there for
for a few hours to play you in a
training game
but i did some preparation for jeffrey
uh we knew the pairings
quite a bit in advance
so
so i did some prep for him but he anyway
surprised me by playing something he had
never played before
i don't think he's ever played the
petrov so that came as quite a surprise
let's go through the game actually and
we were discussing your preparation
because we know you're getting ready for
the candidates
are you using any of the candidates prep
or are you using residual preparation
from previous uh training camps
well okay i mean you know that uh we
prepared this line for the world
championship match in
in 2018
um but i i didn't remember anything like
i mean it was four years ago i just
decided knight c3 is
um it's a rare move but it's transposing
to a big line which normally
um we get if black plays let's say
knight c6 instead of bishop f5
knight c6
castle
bishop e7 knight c3 bishop f5 this is
the usual move order yeah just starting
so
and then we get the game position
and
yeah and knight c3 and bishop f5
so so i was hoping he wouldn't be too
familiar with the line and that seemed
to be the case
but i also
had no familiarity with the line
i think like the main move is queen f5
or rupee one but rookie two caught him
off guard
it seemed very logical to me during the
game so
i went with it i'm just trying to double
rooks and i was very happy with the
position i got i thought i got a very
pleasant amount of pressure
um
yeah i was sort of happy with bishop b5
although it might not i mean it's not
forced of course
i have a number of options including
just taking on d6
but bishop b5 i i liked how it kept the
tension in the position
and yeah then he surprised me
with b5 right
um
i thought queen e3 was clever because
now he's under this very annoying pin
but
maybe it wasn't the best
it look i'm kind of pinned but he's also
pinned so it's hard to say
who's pinned and here he shocked me with
king f7 i was expecting
something else but king f7 allows queen
h6 queen f4 right i figured his idea was
queen f4 king g7 he wants to sacrifice
the c7 pawn get into an end game where
um i'm a pawn but c3 is a very big
weakness
why did you reject queen h6
yeah this was a definitely correct queen
of six king g and knight h2
i realized this after i played knight h2
that
this was the right way to play
that you could have done this instead
it's like the game but he doesn't have
the h5 option right and if bishop f8
knight uh queen to f4 exactly
and now knight g4 is really a big threat
in fact this was real really dangerous
for black yes um what i missed when i
played knight h2
i thought i was
paralyzing him h5 queen f3 but i missed
b4
um
and
yeah and here i was kind of happy with
this rookie six idea
um
bishop h4 i thought i should be much
better
but maybe i shouldn't take on c3 it
turns out that this is actually the key
moment yeah i was thinking about g4 here
and that was the that was the
alternative which is actually according
to the engine super strong for you yeah
uh what did you look at or did you just
think okay i can always come back to i
thought after g4 he has to take
knight takes yeah well you could take on
c3 first i think right
i thought that was what we were looking
at
you can indeed take on c3 and then
knight takes g4
yeah i didn't consider this i was
looking at my g4 immediately and then f5
and this one i didn't really consider
um
i guess it's also quite strong for white
because yeah i can play queen c3 here
and um probably take on e7 93 at some
point and just have
a much much better version of the game
he doesn't have the activity
it was actually a big surprise for us
that uh when you played the move queen
c3
and he has once he played the move rook
b8 he's right in the game yeah i was
also surprised i thought i would be in
time to coordinate but
exactly not at all my king is very weak
so what happened here king d7 knight f1
repeat yeah and this is already
things have you've lost yeah yeah i
didn't see anything
i was even starting i mean it should be
a draw but i was starting to worry that
my king could get under attack
and yeah maybe king g2 because i
well at this point we were both low on
time i was trying to make sure i didn't
get into
terrible time pressure exactly and it's
such a difficult position to
because it's just pure tactics at this
point you know there is no
nothing really guides you here
right general principles be damned
discover check and rook f4 yeah i was
already getting worse um near the end
but
maybe it was always a draw
but i was worried that
you know white white is the one who has
to make a draw here black has no risk
exactly
and that was uh the belligerent move
queen a7 then just at the end it did
turn out that there was a three-move
repetition
um
but uh jeffrey was one was the one who
wanted to be sure i mean obviously at
this point you're ready to claim the
draw yeah he was thinking about how to
um play this he mentioned the move
knight f5 here okay
um after queen d4 queen d4 knight f5 yet
queen h8 king b7
okay
and
knight d5
i really need to get the activity rook
takes a2
and what he was worried about he told me
was queen to c3
but
it seems like he has this move rook 6 to
e2
again it's very complicated it's um but
if i don't have checks i could also lose
right i started to lose all my pawns
queen before the king hides on c6 which
is very important
so he was afraid of this no no he was he
didn't see rook e2 uh so he was thinking
the rook on a2 would be in serious
danger
when he didn't see the move rookie too
well
thank you very much for joining us abby
and sharing your thoughts of this uh
first day thank you thank you and we are
done with the first day out are we yeah
the two uh players in the women's
section that were fighting it out or the
four players that were fighting it out
have finished their game begging as we
saw had defeated catherine sova and uh
in the other game between alice lee and
several in a roller coaster of a game
that was a novel with 12 parts of drama
yeah that was something uh
did manage to
uh draw well they ended up drawing that
that drawn end game and with that we
have every result of the day wow
uh i was gonna say guys uh three
decisive wins in the lady sections three
decisive wins in the open section
or two
that's right yeah two but still five out
of eight not bad it's a good way to
start and with us one of the winners of
the day irina crush starting with a
convincing win thank you alejandro yes
we are handed with the eight-time
national champion irina crusher now this
match almost feels like a clash of
generations you are the established
grand master she's the upper uh coming
how did you approach this match
yeah that's true i mean she's just 14
years old i think right so i mean yeah
some people at some point you're
starting to
to play people that could uh could like
be your daughters right
it's
funny to say that but you know i'm kind
of used to being the youngest player
i've just been you know playing for so
long but yeah i mean how do i approach
this match um you know just this normal
way looking at her games you know
getting sort of a profile of what she
plays which what kind of position she
likes and then figuring out my strategy
and i think you know my idea for this
game worked worked pretty well it
definitely felt like the strategy
especially in the opening played quite
well let's look at the game where do you
feel like you're uh taking over
yeah well um she she didn't play the
move h6 in the opening which um it's
kind of important
um now
yeah like like let's say we go back a
couple of moves um
before let's say
actually right in the beginning
somewhere in the beginning like the move
h6 like she can probably include at
various points but like it really should
come kind of early right because at some
point you might not have it anymore
because of bishop f6 so yeah she should
just be playing the same position with
the move h6 um because that gives her
ideas of g5 now since she played without
this move she didn't really have this h6
g5 id anymore and so she went for knight
c4 which i thought was interesting um
let me go a few moves further
yeah here we are
um so c5 yeah you have to take with the
knight and now knight c4 is pretty much
what black has to do this and try to
gain the tempo on the bishop on
g5 and it was kind of a big moment for
me because at first i was even thinking
like maybe i should castle and i had to
decide between bishop f4 and bishop h4
but ultimately i just went for bishop h4
i stayed on this diagonal
um
decided not to give up the bishop so
easily
and
yeah honestly i just liked my position
here like i grabbed this pawn and
i was surprised that she never
shook him
right i didn't want to take it i mean of
course i liked my position but i
certainly was expecting black to take
this pawn at some point
and here i just have like so many
choices right i went for queen a6 which
just seems like very
simple and playing for c4
um here i'll show you one interesting
tactical point okay so it says double
question mark knight d2 yeah let's keep
going
um knight c4 and here i was looking at
the move
knight f3
and i think you know white is definitely
in a position where they can start
thinking about winning a piece
and the reason i didn't go for this one
uh is because of queen b2 which i think
is the only move and she kind of
annoyingly attacks my rook on c1 so i
cannot capture the knight on d7 so i
didn't really see a way
um past this as queen on b2 is pretty
untouchable so i'm not sure like in what
way knight d2 was like a total blunder
because i didn't see
like how i was winning a piece but what
i went for
you know was still pretty nice for white
your
uh extra pawn up and
well when
we got when we saw a position where your
knight was on d6 like right here we just
like said whoop
that's it irina's just going to uh you
know reel home the victory and you
probably felt that way
that you were doing a very good job for
a very long time
and then you gave her a chance by giving
up your beautiful night
yeah so knight c8 right um yeah of
course i was very happy to get in like
f3 and e4 then i saw she could like try
to trade the knight
you're killing her bishop by putting the
pawn yeah what did i do i went knight c4
i had this yeah funny i i had all these
squares i could go with my knight but
then i finally realized oh you know e5
is an interesting square to try to get
to
um
and looks really really promising and
she went back i think with the b6 right
and put her bishop on age five yeah and
somehow you know it's not so terrible on
h5 because she has ideas of like let's
say king h8 or king h7 and f6 bishop f7
um so this position wasn't as easy for
me as like i was hoping it would be i i
was deciding here between h3 and h4
i went for h3 and of course putting the
king on h2 was one of the best things i
did in this game as it turned out you
know because it was very safe there
right
yeah and how did those nights come off
yes
oh there yeah rook d6 yeah
so you're doing everything that you want
to do yeah
everything was going really well and
then i don't know where should i have
put my knight well
uh i could imagine that you that knight
d3 might have been a decent start
because you could get to play knight f4
yeah
yeah she'll go like queen c2 i guess i
see this is what you were saying yeah i
mean i i didn't think it like it was
that clear since her bishop returns to
f7 and she's got like of course i'm
better but yeah maybe i have a five yeah
i'm thinking
but you know i never wanted her knight
to go to c4 e3 and f1 that was um you
know another thing that
yeah it's interesting but the nitrate
was that bad yeah of course
i could feel that my advantage was you
know
a lot of it gone yes
here
remarkably i think christian helped me
out here i think you were pointing out
the computer was saying bishop c6 and
it's not that bad well even after queen
to d4 i think rook to b4 i think was
played and then no queen to a3 okay
bishop to c6 this was still fine
but i do think that queen d7 bishop b7
was just the wrong way because now you
get to open up the position i think now
you guys yeah this i was happy about
once i got my rook to d7 then you know
you could be winning yeah you finally
got your grippers back on and you went
on to win the game how does it feel uh
behind the chess board once more are you
getting the feeling of the pieces yeah i
think so i think this was a you know a
pretty good game to get into it because
we did kind of get lower on time so
there was that kind of tension at the
end i mean i managed my time okay
but you know when you get down to two or
three minutes um you know you have to be
kind of alert
right you're not cruising anymore when
you've got that little time so you're
you know i think it's good to have a
little bit of that tension in your first
game and fabiano was mentioning
something very interesting uh this time
control that you don't get a second time
control he said he probably played this
type of event 10 years ago when was the
last time you remember playing this type
of yeah this there was a point when this
kind of time control was pretty popular
and i definitely remember playing it i
guess even in maybe in like i don't know
olympiads or world championships i but
um they've moved away from this and it's
true i have not played just pure game 90
in like a really long time
do you feel any extra pressure with
those minutes taking down
yeah i mean i want my opponents to have
less time than me so it's a it's a
little bit less pressure like that way i
mean that's definitely going to be my
goal i think time management is really
important with this time control i mean
i don't think i'm the best you know
having like 30 seconds on the clock so
like i will definitely make an effort to
have more time than my opponents irina
thank you very much for joining us and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you guys
thank you thank you irina and thank you
all for joining us today in the first
round of the american cup we do have
this result between irena crush and
riyan yan she will be
it will be enough for a draw for the
eight-time us women's champion to
advance in the champions bracket but
just to remind everybody what this whole
format is about it's a double
elimination match so tomorrow we are
expecting that some of the games will
some of the matches will be 1-1 which
will lead immediately
to this scenario absolutely we'll have a
playoff tomorrow after the round
and remember one player advances to the
champions bracket the other one moves to
the elimination bracket but tomorrow
we'll know we'll
have the players that lost today must
come back with a victory tomorrow
otherwise they will go down and remember
elimination bracket is rapid
and that puts extra pressure on the
players exactly but i just wanted to ask
you one more time that in case of a
one-on-one match the playoff is tomorrow
yes i understand the uh they'll play two
games of rapid chess game 15 or is it
game 10 plus five it's game 15 plus 10.
game perfect is so close on this
very nice and we have a final guest at
studio
alejandro thank you yasser yes we are
indeed with another victory of today's
round that is begging tokyo genova after
her victory against nemtsova begging
welcome back to the studio welcome back
to st louis this is the first time after
the us chess championships back in st
louis how does that feel thank you very
much it feels great now we are playing
without a mask and the time control is
different i
i'm happy to be here
talk to us a little bit about that time
control and the format of this event
it's a double elimination
robin how does that feel and also the
time control because you don't get the
second time control
yeah i have never played double
animation so it's going to be my first
experience and i'm kind of
very excited about that and when it
comes to time control i like it more
than like having more time sometimes
like
people spend half an hour when they have
already like you losing position after
move 40 which is kind of unpleasant so
here it's faster and i like faster games
more
let's go uh through today's game take us
uh through the opening phase and then
the middle game and when you feel like
you're taking over
to be honest
uh i thought c4 was a wrong move i
thought after knight d2 uh i'm better
and whatever she did in the opening felt
a little bit
as slow for me
and then here i thought i'm better but
then i started to realize i really don't
have anything she played knight d2
and i took on c4
b4
and here i thought she could play rook
d1 instead of rook a2
or rook 81 rook 81 maybe
and then she wants to play bishop c3 and
slowly getting back to pawn
i thought i was much better than i
started to realize i'm not that
like
she's probably going to regain her pawn
yeah slowly she can like develop ruketo
was very strange move after that
it's just still she has some chances of
course here because because she has two
bishops but unfortunately she didn't
have any time
so
she wasn't very precise
and what was the final moment in this
end game or uh
okay here i knew i should uh like
i should be winning slowly even though
we have like different
offices
yeah here i thought maybe f6 instead of
f5
and slowly i have maybe slowly developed
the pieces then i wasn't sure after rook
d2 rook d8 is coming so i thought f5 and
rook d6
is better for me
and at some point i thought maybe it's
it's draw and i cannot win the position
like win the game
at what moment did you feel like you
have lost like around here i i felt like
i i lost con i lost control over the
position it's just like
it felt uh
very
good to have the position but then i
realized it's so hard to play
so somewhere around here you would kind
of reconcile that the game is probably
going to peter out into it yeah i was
hoping that she uh
she will
make a mistake because otherwise it
feels like if she puts bishop isabel or
something like bishop g5 it's
immediately draw so i started to
like
realize that and try to escape that
positions and luckily she made some
mistakes
so about where did it really really go
wrong now at this point you've got two
connected past pawns yeah and probably
it's already gone here i was confident
that i'm gonna be in the position
unfortunately if you don't have you you
don't have enough time you it's very
hard to protect these positions right
you should be very very precise
everywhere so i was kind of like
i was sure that i'm gonna be in the game
but before after i played f4 i thought
probably she's going to hold the
position i got you and it was a very
strange game because i felt like i was
doing okay and at some point everything
just disappeared
wonderful thank you for sharing thank
you very much and uh we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very much well done
eventful day oh my god yes i mean just
take us through uh the results again
because we've got like five decisive
results five decisive results exactly in
a game number one between dominguez and
shanklin we had a draw
first result of the
2022 american
cup yeah and then aronian won a nice
game against robson i think robson with
some chances to prove that pawn right uh
compensation but didn't really manage to
do so under the time pressure and lost
meanwhile wesley saw game of round
perhaps the game of the tournament
wesley saw against time saving i wish
we'd have had sam here for another hour
at all exactly
a remarkable remarkable game absolutely
and fabiano caron drew against jeffrey
shung both sides perhaps missing a
little bit of chances fabi early on
jeffrey perhaps near the end
instead of taking the repetition
meanwhile in the women's section uh
arena crush did defeat ryan young
perhaps not the best technique but
pretty one-sided game
all throughout
next we have
but it was marred by the time trouble
there yeah and i mean tata
yeah splattered a piece yes yeah pretty
essentially that was unfortunate and in
the game between this was a roller
coaster this guy that gave me something
uh how did alice save it though 12 year
old really tenacious then i have to give
some credit to to stavroula from finding
even some counter play because she was
dead lost strategically right out of the
opening and somehow she managed to draw
that game and there was other one more
game between goldrick beckham
just uh saw defeated catherine
christian final thoughts of the day well
first of all i have to say i love this
format and i love this event already and
i hope all of the events are going to
have this format because it's so
exciting and it pushes the players to
their limits and we see players top
elite level players such as fabiano
corona thinking wait when is the last
time i played this time format when is
the last time i had so much pressure
going uh towards that 40th move probably
10 years ago because after 40 moves you
usually get the second time control i
love it i love this format i love the
event and i'm looking forward to see the
rest of the matches and even more i
think i played world championship in
2004 with this system of 90 plus 30 and
i don't think i've seen it since yeah i
went going back all the way to the first
world knockout in 1996 i do think they
had a 15 minute yeah they had a 15
minute and they got rid of it afterwards
exactly it was too fast but well wow
it's very good for us i'm loving the
format i love the decisive game i like
the double elimination i love the double
elimination you're knocked out but you
still have a life and you have to prove
yourself to come back but you can do it
thank you all for joining us today we'll
be back tomorrow 1pm central with the
second round of the first matches
remember everybody layoffs with the
playoffs everybody that lost today needs
to win to force the playoffs which will
also be played tomorrow the games are of
10 plus five in the playoff format of
course the classical remains on 90 plus
30. see you tomorrow don't miss it that
will be very exciting thank you for
sharing your day with us see you
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you